les auditions de la commission d'enquête
sur l'attribution le contenu et le
contrôle des autorisations de services
de télévision à caractère national sur
la télévision numérique terrestre nous
allons entendre ce matin monsieur roc
Olivier MZ président de l'Autorité de
régulation de la communication
audiovisuelle et numérique à ditarcom
accompagné de monsieur Guillaume
Blanchot directeur général et de Madame
Justine Boniface directrice de cabinet
monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Directeur Général Madame la Directrice
je vous souhaite la bienvenue et je vous
remercie de prendre le temps de répondre
à notre invitation il m'a semblé
particulièrement important de vous
entendre en ouverture de nos auditions
afin de rappeler le droit applicable à
la régulation audiovisuelle et le rôle
de l'arcom je vais vous passer la parole
pour une intervention liminire d'environ
15 minutes qui précédera notre échange
sous forme de questions et réponses à
commencé par celle de notre rapporteur
ensuite nous allons essayer de donner à
chaque député quelques minutes pour vous
questionner je vous remercie également
de nous déclarer tout autre intérêt
public ou privé de influencé vos
déclarations auparavant je vous rappelle
que l'article 6 de l'ordonnance du 17
novembre 1958 relative au fonctionnement
des assemblées parlementaires impose aux
personnes auditionnées par une
commission d'enquête de prêter serment
de dire la vérité toute la vérité rien
que la vérité je vous invite donc madame
messieurs à lever la main droite et à
dire je le jure je le
jure je vous remercie monsieur le
Président vous avez la
parole
monsieur le Président Monsieur le le
rapporteur madame et Messieurs les les
députés les travaux de votre commission
d'enquête porte sur l'une des
principales missions de l'Autorité de
régulation la communication
audiovisuelle et et numérique depuis la
loi du 29 juillet 1982 qui a abrogé le
monopole d'État en matière de
radiodiffusion et celle du 30 septembre
1986 qui a consacré le principe de la
liberté ette communication audiovisuelle
il revient en effet dans notre pays à
une autorité
indépendante d'attribuer les fréquence
assigné au service de la télévision
numérique terrestre la
TNT cette autorité a également la charge
de contrôler les obligations
législatives et conventionnelles fixées
aux éditeurs en contrepartie de
l'utilisation d'une ressource rare
appartenant au domaine public de l'État
la place majeure occupée par les
programmes de radio et télévision dans
la vie quotidienne de nos concitoyens et
dans le débat public leur rôle
prescripteur dans la formation des
opinions leur importance dans la
diffusion de la culture du savoir du
divertissement donne à cette mission une
importance de premier plan et il est à
cet égard tout à fait naturel que le
régulateur don la feuille de route je le
rappelle est fixée par vous-même et
fixée par le législateur en R compte
devant la représentation nationale comme
il le fait très régulièrement et apporte
aujourd'hui sa contribution aux travaux
de votre
commission je souhaiterais si vous le
permettez profiter de ce propos
liminaire pour d'abord rappeler les
caractéristiques et les perspectives de
la TNT je pense c'est important pour les
travaux de votre commission d'avoir
cette toile de fond sur notre notre
paysage et je voudrais ensuite décrire
les les étapes de la procédure
d'attribution des fréquences
et de délivrance des autorisations des
matres ainsi que les
modalités de contrôle des obligations
qui pèseent sur les
chaînes commençons si vous voulez bien
par le paysage de la TNT alors d'abord
de quoi parle-t-on la TNT je le rappelle
c'est un mode de diffusion numérique de
la télévision qui est basé sur l'emploi
d'onde
radioélectrique dont les fréquences sont
planifiées et coordonnées entre les
États
par une agence de l'ONU l'Union
internationale des télécommunications
l'UIT pour la France les bandes de
fréquences sont réparties en fonction de
leur utilisation et c'est l'arcom qui
gère les fréquences qui sont assignées à
l'audiovisuel la France défend
historiquement depuis de nombreuses
années l'importance de préserver une
bande de fréquence dédié consacré à la
TNT et le législateur national vous le
savez a souhaité que cette bande de
fréquence reste affectée à à l'arcom
pour la diffusion de la TNT au moins
jusqu'au 31 décembre 2030 il est prévu
par le législateur un rendez-vous en en
2030 c'est la loi l'article 21 de la loi
du du 30 septembre 86 c'est cette
position qui ne fait pas forcément
consensus il faut le savoir au sein de
l'UIT que la France qui est représentée
par l'Agence nationale des fréquences a
à nouveau porté dans la toute dernière
conférence mondiale des
radioommunications qui s'achève demain à
Dubaï qui se réunit tous les 2 ans et où
cette question vient de façon
récurrente lancé en France
métropolitaine le 31 mars 2005 la TNT
s'est entièrement substitué à la
télévision analogique en 2011 et son
paysage s'est alors structuré autour des
acteurs historiques TF1 M6 et également
de nouveaux entrants aujourd'hui la
plateforme est occupé par 10 groupes
audiovisuels qui sont présents sur la
TNT nationale et qui édit au total 31
services h services sont portés par des
entreprises publiques donc les chaînes
du groupe France Télévision
Arté et les deux chaînes parlementaires
qui se partagent un canal et 23 services
sont privés 18 gratuits 5 payants à ces
chaînes nationale ces 31 services
nationaux s'ajoutent 42 chaînes locales
en métropole qui sont présentes sur
l'ensemble de notre territoire et une
offre spécifique adaptée à chaque
territoire
ultramarin ainsi même si la bande de
fréquence est physiquement limitée on
peut pas autoriser tout sur cette bande
de fréquence mais seulement un certain
nombre de canaux la TNT française se
caractérise aujourd'hui par l'abondance
la diversité de son offre pour les
téléspectateurs et dans ce paysage il
faut intégrer bien évidemment le fait
qu'au-delà de la TNT s'ajoute
aujourd'hui un peu plus de 200 chaînes
qui sont disponibles par d'autres
réseaux plus c'est considérable à la
date où je vous parle environ 360 360
services de médias audiovisuel à la
demande qui sont déclaré ou conventionné
par le
régulateur rappelle ce panorama pour
bien vient dire que le monde de la
télévision que nous allons évoquer ce
matin le monde de la TNT ne s'arrête pas
loin de là à cette seule
TNT j'ajoute enfin dans ce constat que
tous les services accessibles sur la TNT
sont aujourd'hui diffusés en haute
définition à l'exception de deux
services qui sont LCI la chaîne
d'information LCI et la chaîne Paris-
première qui est diffusée sur la TNT
payante et par ailleurs don information
utile je pense pour votre commission à
la demande du gouvernement l'arcom a
autorisé tout récemment vient juste
d'autoriser le groupe France
Télévision àmettre en Ultra Haute
Définition donc et la norme supérieure
le 4K comme on dit sur France 2 et
France 3 dans la perspective des Jeux de
Paris 2024 c'est un mouvement qui est
aujourd'hui lancé je l'évoque parce que
diffusant ultra haute définition diffusé
en haute définition consomme plus de
fréquence qu'en simple
définition quelles sont aujourd'hui la
situation et les perspectives de la
plateforme
TNT de manière globale vous le savez je
l'ai évoqué récemment encore devant la
la commission des affaires culturelles
de votre assemblée devant celle du Sénat
hier encore les groupes audiovisuels
nationaux nos groupes nationaux sont
affectés par des transformations très
profondes très rapides de leur
environnement d'abord les usages sont en
train d'évoluer extrêmement vite sous
l'effet de la transition numérique on
mesure aujourd'hui un nombre d'écrans
qui se démultiplie dans les foyers
français grosso modo six écrans par
foyer en incluant naturellement les les
smartphone mais qui sont un vecteur
d'accès au contenu audiovisuel de
deuxième tendance qu'on observe c'est la
baisse de la durée desé coûes
individuelle de la télévision euh
environ 20 % sur les seules trois
dernières années c'est une baisse
tendantielle en corolire l'âge moyen du
public de la télévision traditionnelle
augmente il est en moyenne maintenant
tenant pratiquement de 58 ans plus vous
le savez monsieur le Président pour le
service public
ensuite les chaînes de télévision
subissent une conquérence très forte
d'acteurs internationaux extrêmement
puissants au plan technologique comme au
plan financier d'un côté les plateformes
de de streaming par abonnement chaque
foyer français plus de la moitié des
foyers français pardon disposeent
aujourd'hui d'au moins un abonnement à
une plateforme de de streaming et puis
peut-être surtout les Gafa capte
aujourd'hui une part essentielle de la
croissance du marché publicitaire
consacré au médias alors que cette
recette publicitaire et naturellement la
source quasi exclusive de financement
des chaînes gratuites privées c'est
c'est une question très très lourde d'u
elle va être au centre des états
généraux de l'information naturellement
parce qu'elle met en question le modèle
économique de nos médias presse écrite
radio télévision et il y a derrière ça
chacun le sait ici un enjeu de
souveraineté très important
donc les groupes audiovisuels
aujourd'hui qu'ils soient public ou
privés sont tous confrontés à la
nécessité de s'adapter à ce nouvel
environnement d'aller chercher les
publics là où ils sont notamment les les
plus jeunes en renforçant une stratégie
digitale et
éditorial de son côté la plateforme TNT
aujourd'hui est de plus en plus
concurrencée par d'autres modes de
diffusion donc ça aussi je pense un
élément d'appréciation important à avoir
en tête aujourd'hui c'est un peu moins
20 % des foyers français qui dépendent
de la seule TNT pour accéder à la
télévision ce sont principalement dans
les données que nous avons il faut là
aussi l'intégrer des foyers plutôt
modestes des foyers plutôt âgés des
foyers plutôt situés en zone rural à la
seule réception hertienne donc la
fameuse antenne rateau qui couvrait nos
toits et qui est couvre encore en partie
s'ajoute dorénavant vous le savez
d'autres modes de distribution le
satellite bien sûr la la box don le
déploiement s'est accéléré avec la fibre
et maintenant et surtout l'accès via via
Internet qui va se développer de façon
très sensible dans les années qui
viennent près de 90 % des foyers
français aujourd'hui sont équipés d'un
téléviseur ayant accès à Internet
possède une télévision connectée et
l'écran de télévision est devenu
maintenant en réalité un magasin
d'application à l'instar de vos de vos
smartphones je donne ce chiffre qui est
toujours frappant 30 % du temps passé à
visionner YouTube aujourd'hui se fait
devant le
téléviseur pour autant malgré ses
évolutions de fond la TNT conserve dans
les usages un élément central c'est un
mode de diffusion structurant pour le
secteur audiovisuel pourquoi parce que
d'abord la TNT permet l'accès à ses
contenus sur l'ensemble du
territoire c'est une offre qui est
gratuite c'est une offre qui est
diversifiée c'est une offre qui est
centré autour d'une numérotation simple
qui donne une forte notoriété au aux
chaînes de télévision c'est enfin mode
de diffusion qui se fait sans
intermédiation et donc sans utilisation
des données personnelles des
téléspectateurs et enfin élément non
négligeable également dans dans le
contexte dans lequel nous sommes entrés
depuis quelques années c'est un outil
plus sobre au plan énergétique que les
autres modes de diffusion et donc la TNT
reste un élément majeur d'aménagement de
notre territoire de cohésion de nos
territoires en particulier bien sûr dans
les zones faiblement équipées en
infrastructure numérique donc en
conclusion de cette présentation des
perspectiv la TNT je soulignerai que
quel que soit leur mode de diffusion les
chaînes de la TNT garde un très fort
pouvoir fédérateur je dirais même un
puissant pouvoir fédérateur que ce soit
en matière d'information que ce soit en
matière de divertissement que ce soit en
matière d'accès à la culture s'il
fallait s'en convaincre il suffit de
regarder le nombre de téléspectateurs au
premier match de l'équipe de France de
de rugby le nombre de téléspectateurs
pour assister au débat du second tour de
l'élection présidentielle ou ou bien
d'autres événements que chacun peut
avoir en tête
ici après ce rapide panorama venons-en
maintenant à la procédure aujourd'hui en
vigueur pour attribuer les autorisations
sur la TNT et au contrôle au modalité de
contrôle des obligations des
éditeurs la procédure d'attribution des
des fréquences est extrêmement encadrée
par la loi et elle se fait sous le
contrôle du juge administratif l'arcom
la met très souvent très souvent en
œuvre T pour les chaînes nationales qui
vont occuper les travaux de votre
commission que pour les chaînes de la
TNT locale et également je dirais
presque surtout pour les très nombreux
services de radio qui composent notre
paysage audiovisuel je rappelle ce ce
chiffre qui est toujours spectaculaire
il y a plus de 1000 radios en France et
donc chaque année nous utilisationsons
cette procédure de l'appel à candidature
euh de façon même parfois plusieurs fois
par année pour attribuer les fréquences
dans ce domaine la seule exception à
cette procédure ce sont les chaînes
publiques pour lesquelles vous le savez
le législateur a donné au gouvernement
un droit de préemption sur la ressource
radioélectrique donc le gouvernement
nous fait savoir à nous autorités de
régulation le souhait
de mobiliser telle ou telle fréquence au
service du service public et c'est une
compétence qui est quasiment liée pour
l'autorité quelles sont donc les étapes
de la procédure fixées par la loi en
premier lieu donc l'article 31 de la loi
de 86 dispose que
l'arcom doit procéder à une consultation
publique quand les décisions
d'attributions sont je cite susceptibles
de modifier de façon importante le
marché en cause dans les faits
l'autorité y a recours de manière
systématique pour la TNT nationale
elle l'a fait en 2020 à l'échéance de
l'autorisation de Canal plus elle l'a
fait en 2002 à l'échéance des
autorisations de TF1 et de M6 elle vient
de le faire pour les échéances de 2025
en lançant le 13 juillet dernier une
consultation publique et je vous informe
donc que la la synthèse de cette
consultation publique sera publiée et
bien sûr communiquée à votre commission
dans les tout prochains
jours en second lieu après cette
consultation publique qui permet à
chacun aux acteurs du secteur mais mais
à tous ceux qui souhaitent s'exprimer de
de faire connaître leur point de vue et
leur regard sur cette échéance en
deuxième lieu donc après cette
consultation la loi prévoit que quand on
procède à une consultation publique donc
manière systématique je je l'ai dit pour
la TNT nationale
l'arcom procède également à une étude
d'impact notamment économique dit la loi
étude d'impact qu'il est également tenu
que l'autorité est également tenu de
rendre
publque nous finalisons actuellement
cette cette étude on examinait pas plus
tard
qu'hier son son contenu c'est un
document très riche très dense en
information qui donnera un panorama très
complet sur le paysage actuel de de
l'audiovisuel français de de la TNT et
notamment de ses enjeux économiques qui
je pense sera très utile pour les
travaux de votre commission nous allons
l'adopter dans dans les prochains jours
et donc elle sera publiée en tout état
de cause avant la fin de cette année et
là aussi vous pourrez
naturellement on veillera à vous à vous
la communiquer parce que je pense
qu'elle sera très utile pour les travaux
de votre commission consultation
publique étude d'impact
en 3ème lieu une fois ces deux étapes
préparatoires accomples la loi prévoit
que les autorisations sont accordées à
l'issue d'un appel à candidature dont là
aussi le texte est rendu
public l'article 31 de la loi de
86 fixe très précisément et très
limitativement les éléments que
l'autorité peut arrêter dans le texte de
l'appel la loi précise notamment les
catégories de services concernées est-ce
que le service est gratuit est-ce que le
service est payant et
elle précise les éléments que le dossier
de candidature doit
contenir naturellement la personne
morale qui candidate le contenu de la
programmation qui est proposée les
éléments financiers à l'appui du projet
qui est porortter la couverture du
service qu'il est proposé de de réaliser
les modalités de
commercialisation les données techniques
associées le délai de mise en
exploitation du
service donc c'est très précisément
énuméré une fois encore dans cet article
31 de la loi à contrario au regard du
principe constitutionnel de liberté de
communication l'autorité n'est pas
habilité à fixer des conditions dans
l'appel aux candidatures qui reviendrait
d'une façon ou d'une autre à contraindre
la ligne éditoriale proposée par les
candidats s'agissant des échéances de
2025 cet appel le collège n'en a pas
encore délibéré mais cet appel devrait
être lancé au début de l'année
2024 au terme du délai de de réponse à
l'appel l'arcom publie la liste des
candidatures qui sont déclarées receva
sont déclaré recevables les candidatures
qui remplissent les conditions fixées
dans l'appel à candidature les dossiers
font l'objet d'une instruction très
approfondie de la part des des services
de l'autorité sous l'autorité de son
directeur général qui m'accompagne ce
matin service dont je veux saluer devant
la représentation nationale une nouvelle
fois la très solide expérience la très
solide exp très solide
expertise je suis un très vieux
serviteur de l'État maintenant au terme
de sa carrière et au cours de ma
carrière il me sera rarement donné la
chance de diriger une administration
aussi brillante et aussi compétente
l'arcom procède ensuite à l'audition
publique des candidats dans le strict
respect du principe d'égalité même même
durée de temps d'expression même
organisation du du déroulé de l'audition
avant de procéder enfin à la sélection
du ou des
candidats par l'autor
autorité sur quel critère se prononce
l'autorité pour attribuer les fréquence
là aussi la
loi fixe la feuille de route de
l'autorité éclairé par le juge
administratif je rappelle que la
régulation a vu le jour grosso modo dans
les années 80 et qu'on dispose
maintenant d'un peu plus de 40 ans de
jurisprudence du Conseil d'État qui est
notre juge tutellaire très présent dans
notre
activité la loi dit que l'arcom apprécie
l'intérêt de chaque projet pour le
public donc l'intérêt pour le public au
regard des impératifs prioritaires que
sont la sauvegarde du pluralisme des
courant d'expression
socioculturelle la diversité des
opérateurs et la nécessité d'éviter les
abus de position dominant ainsi que les
pratiques entravant le libre exercice de
la concurrence il ressort précisément de
la jur prudence administrative à
laquelle je faisais allusion que ces
critères donc l'intérêt du public le
pluralisme sont des critères
prioritaires qui s'imposent à l'autorité
d'autres critères bien sûr peuvent être
pris en compte pour départager les
projets qui présenter trait un intérêt
équivalent j'en cite quelquesuns
l'expérience du candidat ça va s'en dire
les engagements qu'ils peuvent prendre
en matière de financement de la
production le respect au aussi des
principes qui sont mentionnés au début
de la loi de 86 je pense à ceux relatifs
à à l'honnêteté à l'indépendance au
pluralisme de l'information la
représentation de la diversité de la
société française dans les programmes et
puis naturellement l'autorité peut
décider de rejeter àinitio un dossier
lorsque le candidat ne fournit pas à ses
yeux les garanties suffisantes sur la
viabilité économique du
service les autorisations doivent être
attribu dans un délai de 8 mois à
compter de la clôture des candidatures
pour une durée maximum de 10 ans et la
loi conditionne vous le savez également
la délivrance d'une autorisation à la
conclusion d'une convention entre
l'arcom et la personne morale candidate
qui a été
sélectionné donc comme vous le voyez la
procédure telle qu'elle est définie très
précisément par le législateur est
soumise à trois principes fondamentaux
la légalité ça va s'en dire l'égalité
des candidat et la
transparence elle repose aussi sur les
règles qui fondent l'action du
régulateur
l'indépendance
l'impartialité et la collégialité on
pourra revenir sur euh l'organisation de
la régulation dans notre pays si vous le
souhaitez mais ces principes sont au
cœur du modèle de régulation euh
français et de ce point de vue-là je le
dis bien sûr devant votre commission je
serai moi-même astreint au respect du
principe d'impartialité donc vous
comprendrez que je ne porte pas de
jugement sur des éditeurs qui très
vraisemblablement seront candidats à
l'échéance qui vienne pour ne pas vicier
purement et simplement la procédure que
nous allons devoir mener à bien dans
dans les semaines et dans les mois qui
viennent je termine si vous le voulez
bien avec les modalités du contrôle que
l'arcom exerce sur les obligations
légales ou conventionnelles qui pèsent
sur les
chaînes il convient au préalable de
rappeler c'est important c'est même
essentiel que l'autorité intervient au
cœur d'une liberté publique fondamentale
qui est consubstantielle à notre vie
démocratique la liberté de
communication c'est un principe vous le
savez pas devant le législateur je vais
le rappeler c'est un principe de nature
constitutionnelle qui est extrêmement
protégé par la loi qui est extrêmement
protégé également par les juridictions
nationales et les juridictions
européennes comme son titre l'indique la
loi de 1986 au même titre que la loi
1881 sur la presse est d'abord une loi
de
liberté c'est son titre c'est son
premier article l'article l'arcom est
garante de cette liberté dit la loi et
donc elle n'intervient jamais a priori
sur les programmes qui sont diffusé sur
les antennes
elle n'est pardon de rappeler ce truisme
elle n'est en aucune façon une autorité
de censure elle n'est en aucune façon
une police de la pensée et il ne revient
forth heureusement pas à une autorité
administrative de déterminer la ligne
éditoriale des médias et en particulier
des chaînes de radio et de télévision
qui sont dans notre périmètre de
régulation néanmoins le législateur a
fixé des limites comme la loi comme la
Constitution l'autorise des limites à
l'exercice de cette liberté et à
confieré au régulateur le soin d'en
assurer le respect sous le contrôle là
aussi du
juge l'impact des médias audiovisuels
sur notre société justifie chacun
comprend la définition d'obligation
relative au contenu des programmes qu'il
diffusent il en va ainsi du respect du
pluralisme il en va ainsi de la
sauvegarde de l' publ il en va aussi de
l'honnêteté de l'indépendance de la
rigueur de la présentation de
l'information ou encore de la
préservation des droit de la personne ou
de la protection de la jeunesse tout ne
peut pas être dit ou montré à
l'antenne sur ces différents
fondements législatifs conventionnels ou
qui reposeent sur nos propres
délibérations puisque l'autorité dispose
d'un certain pouvoir réglementaire
l'arcom peut être amené à intervenir et
le cas échéant à prononcer des sanctions
à l'égard des chaînes qui ne
respecteraient pas leurs obligations
elle le fait on pourrait y revenir au
cours de cette audition si vous le
souhaitez là aussi de manière collégiale
toutes les décisions d'intervention sont
délibéré par le collège sans exception
elle le fait bien sûr en toute
indépendance après une instruction
toujours approfondi par les services
elle le fait également conformément à la
loi dans le respect du principe de
proportionnalité les interventions du
législateur et notamment ses sanctions
doivent être proportionnelles dit la loi
et aussi avec des garanties procédurales
et notamment des procédures
contradictoires qui font partie là
encore tout naturellement dans le champ
d'une liberté publique qui font partie
des garanties fondamentales prévues par
la loi je le redis ici nous bénéficions
aujourd'hui de 40 ans de jurisprudence
pour éclairer les motifs qui peuvent
justifier ou non une intervention du
régulateur auprès d'un éditeur il faut
d'ailleurs rappeler c'est important que
la mission de l'autorité ne porte que
sur la responsabilité de l'éditeur au
regard de ses obligations elle vient
donc en complément de celle du juge
judiciaire qui lui seul peut se
prononcer lorsqu'un propos tenu à
l'antenne constitue une atteinte
réprimée par la loi du 29 juillet
1881 donc sanctionnons quand nous
sanctionnons c'est l'éditeur nous
sanctionnons non ce n'est pas la
personne qui s'est exprimée et qui est à
l'origine du manquement de de
l'éditeur monsieur le Président Monsieur
le rapporteur mesdames et Messieurs les
les députés au terme de de ce propos
introductif avant de répondre à vos
questions je voudrais souligner ici
l'importance des mutations qui sont à
l'œuvre dans le paysage audiovisuel et
et numérique à votre initiative et pour
accompagner ce ce mouvement le
régulateur c'est considérablement trans
transformé depuis 5 ans j'arrive au
terme de mon de mon mandat en l'espace
de de 5 ans expérience administrative
rare dans la vie d'un d'un serviteur de
l'État j'aurais connu 13 textes
législatifs qui seront venus impacter
l'autorité et et mon mandat n'est pas
encore complètement fini donc il pas
exclu j'en vois encore quelques-uns
c'est considérable l'autorité que je
préside aujourd'hui n'est plus celle que
j'ai connu au moment de sa mise en place
au début des années des années 80
elle est tjours 'hui en partie engagé
vous le
savez dans la communication numérique
qui est bien évidemment l'enjeu de
demain c'est un enjeu essentiel pour les
années qui viennent et nous sommes dès à
présent mobilisés avec la Commission
européenne avec nos homologues européen
dans la mise en œuvre du règlement
européen sur les services numériques le
fameux DSA pour mieux lutter contre les
contenu illicite la manipulation de
l'information la haine en ligne qui
prospère et qui aujourd'hui aujourd'hui
doivent mobiliser largement nos énergies
en tout cas soyez assurés de de
l'engagement du collège que je préside
du collège de l'autorité de l'ensemble
des services de l'autorité pour exercer
les missions que vous lui avez confié
avec rigueur indépendance impartialité
conformément à à la hautere
responsabilité qui est la nôtre je vous
remercie je suis monsieur le Président à
disposition de la commission pour
répondre à vos
questions merci beaucoup monsieur le
Président avant de donner la parole
rapporteur peut-être deux questions la
première quelles sont les principales
évolutions de la régulation dont vous
venez de parler des chaînes de
télévision autant réglementair que
législative depuis 86 et la deuxième
question peut-être un comparatif avec
quelques modèles on va dire les plus les
plus les plus parlants au niveau
européen donc quelle différence de
régulation par exemple avec l'Allemagne
ou le
Royaume-Uni merci Monsieur le le
président donc notre modèle de
régulation il a il a vu le jour en
réalité assez récemment puisque comme
souvent dans notre pays beaucoup de
choses procèdent
àinio de l'État c'est l'État qui
apportait jusqu'au début des années 80
un temps que les moins de 20 ans ne
peuvent pas connaître qui apportait la
radiodiffusion et la télévision jusqu'au
début des années 80 la télévision était
entièrement entre les mains de l'État
avec un nombre de chaînes très limité et
il en était de même pour la radio et
c'est au début des années 80 que ce
paysage s'est ouvert avec d'un côté le
mouvement de libération des ondes pour
la radio c'était le fameux mouvement des
des radios libres que que vous
connaissez puis l'arrivée progressive de
premiers acteurs privés euh l'un temp
marquant ayant été la privatisation de
de TF1 en 1900 en 1987 et avec
l'ouverture de ce paysage il a fallu
mettre en place comme dans toutes les
démocraties une autorité indépendante
pour organiser ce paysage organiser la
bande FM pour permettre aux radio de
diffuser dans des conditions d'écoute
satisfaisantes pour les les Français
sinon elle se seraient toutes brouillé
les unes entre les autres et puis en
même temps pour fixer le cadre et les
obligations applicables au secteur donc
c'est une c'est un modèle récent une
quarantaine d'années maintenant si je
prends les États-Unis le premier modèle
de régulation date des années 30 nos
homologues américains de la FCC euh
c'est ensuite un modèle de régulation
qui est très élaboré avec un corpus
juridique extrêmement dense une fois
encore on est en
France donc la loi est extrêmement
élaboré c'est la loi de 86 donc nous
mettons toujours en œuvre c'est une loi
qui a été modifiée grosso modo 90 fois
et quand je dis modifieré c'est plutôt
complété enrichi avec une extension des
champs de régulation que le législateur
a confié à cette autorité je vais je
vais y
revenir articuler sur deux principes un
premier principe qui est celui de la
liberté donc la loi a voulu dans ce
modèle consacrer la liberté des médias
au moment où on sortait du monopole
d'État la volonté du législateur était
de permettre aux médias comme la loi
1880 de permettre aux médias de d'avoir
un accès un accès libre et d'élargir
l'offre dans une approche pluraliste et
en même temps de l'autre c'est un un
cadre qui repose sur la protection des
publics donc on est constamment dans
cette balance entre la protection d'une
liberté fondamentale la liberté de
communication la liberté éditoriale des
chaînes la liberté d'expression et de
l'autre la protection des des publics
c'est une régulation donc qui repose sur
une autorité collégiale donc avec un
collège qui est aujourd'hui composé de
de neuf membres donc c'est une autorité
qui de ce point de vue-là un collège
plus important que celle de nos de nos
voisins beaucoup d'autorités ont des
culages plus petits
ce collège de neuf membres je le
rappelle est désigné par cinq autorités
différentes trois par le président du du
Sénat trois par le président de
l'Assemblée nationale un par le
vice-président du Conseil d'État un par
le premier président de la Cour de
cassation un par le Président de la
République avec validation par les
commissions parlementaires un régime
d'incompatibilité extrêmement sévère on
peut bien évidemment quand on est membre
du collège rien faire d'autre que siéger
au sein de ce collège et quand on quitte
ce collège pendant 3 années en substance
euh on ne peut pas faire grand-chose
très un cadre très contraignant alors on
diffère de nos de nos voisins européens
à certains points de vue d'abord on a
des modèles de régulation plus intégrés
que les nôtres qui valent dans plusieurs
pays je pense la Grande-Bretagne qui
fait plus partie de de l'union avec nos
homologues de lovecom ou nos amis
italiens de la même façon nos amis de la
gcom ou nos amis espagnols où la
régulation est convergée entre les téléc
communication et l'audiovisuel donc mes
homologues anglais italiens espagnol
traitent à la fois des télécoms et de
l'audiovisuel comme si le l'arcom était
fusionné avec l'arcepep c'est un un
débat qui a été un petit peu récurrant
dans notre pays qui à ce stade n'a pas
été tranché quand quand j'ai pris mes
fonctions on a traité ce problème en
signant une convention avec l'arsp et en
créant un service commun pour les sujets
d'intérêt commun au aux deux autorités
mais point de vu là on un modèle un peu
différent de on a des tailles de
régulateurs qui sont très différents en
Europe l'arcom est un des régulateur
important par sa longue histoire
maintenant et par sa taille beaucoup de
régulateurs sur la frontière orientale
du continent sont des petits régulateurs
bien évidemment pas une
appréciation sur la nature de leur
activité mais c'est souvent des
régulateurs qui qui étai jusque là les
services d'un ministère du pays concerné
et qui qui se sont autonomisés sous
l'effet de la réglementation européenne
directive SMA Paquet Télécom et
maintenant avec le nouveau texte en
cours d'adoption en Europe sur la
liberté des médias l'mpha qui qui
consacre la nécessité d'avoir des
régulateurs des régulateur indépendant
et et autonome c'est une régulation la
nôtre donc je disais qui a un corpus
juridique extrêmement extrêmement dense
qui repose donc sur des services
centraux avec la loi de finance pour
2024 l'autorité rassemblera 400
collaborateurs l'année prochaine elle a
la particularité d'avoir des antennes
dans chaque région française 16
implantations si j'inclus les les outr
mers implantations locales qui ont qui
sont le correspondant naturel des médias
de proximité et notamment des radios
locales qui sont très nombreuses très
nombreuses dans notre pays euh voilà je
pense avoir à peu près répondu et
lesmission donc l'mission historique
c'est celle qui nous occupe ce matin
donc l'attribution des autorisations des
maîtres et le contrôle des obligations
donc une obligation technico-juridique
je
dirais une
responsabilité démocratique et le
contrôle du pluralisme permettre à
toutes les formations politiques qui
concourent à notre débat démocratique
d'avoir un accès équitable aux médias
donc c'est une mission qu'on exerce tout
au long de l'année mais aussi de façon
renforcée en période électorale à ce
titre j'écris à chaque président de
groupe politique au président des
assemblées de manière régulière pour
leur communiquer ces temps de parole et
et les équilibres qui sont qui sont
respectés c'est également une régulation
qui a une très forte dimension
culturelle puisque vous savez que notre
modèle de financement du cinéma et de la
production audiovisuelle repose sur des
contributions des médias pourcentage du
Chi d'affaires c'est nous qui contrôlons
ces obligations et qui contrôlons au
même même titre la protection du droit
des auteurs avec la lutte contre le
contre le piratage et ce qui s'est
beaucoup beaucoup développé ces
dernières années c'est ce que
j'appellerai la la responsabilité
sociétale des médias la dimension
sociétale de la régulation
avec des
interventions sur les thématiques de
protection de la jeunesse d'égalité
entre les femmes et et les hommes de
santé d'environnement naturellement
maintenant donc tout un champ de
compéten de juste représentation de la
diversité de la société française donc
tout un champ sociétal très important ça
c'est le cœur des missions
traditionnelles et se sont ajoutés
depuis 2018 maintenant depuis la
première loi française relative à la
lutte contre la manipulation de
l'information jusqu'à l'adoption du
règlement européen tout récent sur les
services numériques un investissement
progressif de l'autorité dans le champ
des grands acteurs du du
numérique donc on a dans notre périmètre
maintenant aussi bien TF1 M6 le service
public canal plus le groupe energy le
groupe Altis que Netflix Disney Amazon
Apple ou les grands réseaux sociaux avec
lesquels nous sommes amenés à à
dialoguer j'allais dire quasi
quotidiennement maintenant donc c'est un
modèle en en transformation très très
profonde comme je comme je le disais
tout à
l'heure merci monsieur le président jeis
maintenant donner la parole à Monsieur
le rapporteur qui pourra regrouper ses
ses questions par thème et monsieur le
Président vous pourrez répondre donc à
chaque fois par groupe de questions
thématique monsieur le
rapporteur merci monsieur le Président
merci monsieur le Président
euh pour cette présentation extrêmement
intéressante et riche euh je vais
essayer de procéder par des questions un
peu brèves comme ça pour vous permettre
à la fois d'être aussi vous-même bref et
puis un peu précis et comme ça on aura
la possibilité aussi pour tous nos
collègues d'avoir un temps de
d'expression important
euh en la première des questions que je
me pose elle porte vraiment sur le
fonctionnement très concret euh de
l'arcom vous l'avez dit les missions
sont extrêmement nombreuses nous on
s'attache dans cette commission un sujet
finalement qui n'est pas du tout
secondaire qui est historique et très
important mais qui n'est qu'une partie
des des des
fonctions j'aimerais connaître un on
vous demandera un organigramme précis de
l'arcom avec les chefs de bureau et
cetera pour pouvoir
évaluer comment chaque mission mobilise
le le le personnel mais j'aimerais
savoir quels sont vos outils techniques
pour faire une forme de monitoring sur
sur les chaînes de
télévision alors les effectifs je l' dit
environ 400 donc en 2024 avec ces
implant sttion locale un organigramme
qu'on va bien évidemment vous vous
communiquer comme vous venez d' d'en
exprimer le le
souhait sur pour répondre précisément à
votre question dès qu'un signalement
nous est nous est prononcé donc qu'on
instruit l'examen d'un d'un programme
nous avons accès aux images ou aux sons
et on peut revisionner la globalité de
la séquence sur laquelle on est saisi et
sur laquelle on va être amené à à
statuer donc on a un outil qui résulte
d'un acccord que nous avons avec Lina
qui nous permet d'avoir accès à la
totalité des contenus et quand on est
euh sensibilisé ou alert sur des chaînes
étrangères mais qui diffusent sur notre
territoire par voie satellitaire on a la
possibilité d'avoir accès à ces contenus
et de les monitorer pour reprendre
l'expression pour pouvoir apprécier si
la nature des contenus est problématique
au regard de de la de la loi que nous
mettons que nous mettons en
œuvre donc l'arcom est entre guillemets
tributaire des signalements il y a pas
une forme de de Big vous n'êtes pas une
sorte de Big Brother qui suivrait la
totalité des programmes h 24 non l'arcom
effectivement merci de votre question
parce que c'est un thème qui revient
quand même assez régulièrement donc je
n'ai pas dans mon bureau 31 écrans qui
correspondent aux 31 chaînes de la TNT
mon métier n'est pas de regarder matin
midi et soir quoi quoi que je les
regarde beaucoup les programmes de
télévision et et de juger ce ce qu'il en
est là pratique de l'arcom c'est
effectivement de fonctionner à partir
des signalements qui lui sont faits donc
comme je l'ai dit nous n'intervenons
jamais à priori ça va s'en dire hein on
ne soumet pas à l'arcom les programmes
en amont et l'arcom n'a pas à autoriser
tel ou tel programme il intervient à
postérior l'arcom peut se saisir et ça
nous arrive de nous autoaisir mais en
règle générale et à forcerie maintenant
à l'air des réseaux sociaux c'est par
alerte que que l'autorité
fonctionne ce qui a un point effet euh
si je vous comprends bien que ce qui
pourrait être caractérisé comme des
éléments d'ambiance pourrait vous
échapper d'une certaine façon quand si
vous n'avez pas si vous n'avez pas un
signalement continu sur un problème
précis vous ne pouvez pas caractériser
entre guillemets l'ambiance d'une chaîne
l'ambiance idéologique si je puis dire
euh la la ou le goût d'une chaîne
immodérée pour la violence par exemple
ou et
cetera si si l'ambiance ne nous échappe
pas d'abord nous regardons tous le
collège composé de neuf membres comme je
l'ai rappelé nous regardons tous les
programmes de télévision les services
bien évidemment le le font et si je
regarde mon expérience en tout cas
depuis depuis 5 ans je n'ai pas
connaissance qu'une ambiance ne nous ait
pas été signalée le cas échant de façon
répétée d'ailleurs y compris dans la
période récente oou qu'un programme
soulevant une difficulté ne nous ait pas
été signalé la tendance a été plutôt
grosso modo pour vous donner un ordre de
grandeur je sais pas les chiffres exacts
pour la l'année écoulée mais on doit
être aux alentours de 50000 signalements
donc c'est c'est pas négligeable on a eu
des pics l'année où je prenais mes
fonctions je crois qu'on était a-delà de
70000 quand je dis 70000 ça veut pas
dire ou 50000 ça veut pas dire 50000
programmes qui ont fait problème puisque
bien évidemment les les saisines peuvent
s'accumuler on peut avoir un incident
sur une chaîne qui suscite ou un
dérappage sur une chaîne qui suscite
beaucoup beaucoup de signalement ou à
l'inverse d'avoir un signalement
individuel sur tel sur tel ou tel
programme
encore une fois très concrètement
comment on évite l'engorgement comment
vous faites pour traiter un pic de
signalement parce que j'imagine que ça
se passe de différentes façons par
courrier par mail alors la saisine de
l'arcom se fait traditionnellement par
internet donc il y a sur le site de
l'arcom vous le verrez un bouton que
nous avons revu dans son mode de
fonctionnement pour essayer de le rendre
un peu plus convivial donc en une minute
une minute et demi 2 minutes maximum
vous signalez le programme que vous avez
vu la chaîne l'horaire la nature de ce
qui vous a heurté ou ou choqué et
ensuite c'est dispatché dans dans les
services ça donne toujours lieu un
revisionnage bien évidemment de la part
des services ou une réécoute du
programme j'insiste là-dessus parce que
notamment avec le développement des
réseaux sociaux beaucoup de signalements
peuvent être des signalements tronqués
et dès que vous les remettez en
perspective on a tout de suite une
appréciation différente de la de la
séquence donc il y a toujours ce
visionnage pour bien apprécier en
perspective ce qu'il en est il y a
toujours une analyse juridique qui est
faite de la séquence est-ce que cette
séquence pose problème au regard des
dispositions de la loi au regard des
obligation conventionnelle de de
l'éditeur c'est ensuite examiné une fois
que les services ont fait ce travail par
un groupe de travail dans lequel siège
un un ou deux membres du collège qui
examine le travail mené par les services
qui éventuellement demande une
investigation complémentaire sur tel ou
tel point qui dégage une position est-ce
que le groupe de travail pense qu'il y a
plutôt matière à intervenir ou pas si
oui sous quelle forme et ensuite
l'affaire vient devant le collège et
donc tous les mercredis puisque le
collège se réunit tous les mercredis
parfois plus mais c'est le le jour
habituel tous les mercredis nous nous
prononçons sur un certain nombre de
séquences qui nous ont été
signalées le nombre est important c'est
vrai euh quand je suis arrivé l'autorité
avec une certaine lenteur on a essayé
d'accélérer ce temps de ce temps
d'expression de la part de l'autorité et
donc on a une procédure j'allais dire
plus rapide pour des affaires d'une
certaine gravité par la nature du
manquement qui s'est opéré c'est une
chose d'être saisie qui nous arrive
régulièrement sur un mot de Fran anglais
utilisé par un animateur ou un
journaliste çaen est une autre d'être
saisi pour une incitation à la haine un
propos raciste ou ou de nature
antisémite donc
on comme comme on dit dans ma maison mè
on AJE nos nos no nos efforts nos
diligences aux enjeux
euh et voilà et je pense que maintenant
euh on nous fait grief parfois de de
statuer trop trop lentement je pense que
sur pas mal d'exemples récents on a
montré qu'on avait bien progressé sur ce
point là et il va s'en dire que toutes
nos interventions y compris les
interventions en terme de sanction quand
on est amener en prononcer on pourra y
revenir si vous le souhaitez sont
infiniment plus rapides que des
procédures
judiciaires on ne peut que vous donner
raison compte tenu de la durée des
procédures euh en
justice précisément est-ce que vous
pourriez nous présenter l'éventail des
rappels à l'ordre des sanctions des
observations vous êtes en mesure de de
prononcer alors il y a une pratique que
l'autorité a élaboré au fil de son
histoire au fil des des 40
ans il y a la
nonintervention je je l'évoque parce que
on peut être saisi et ça arrive
régulièrement d'être saisi sur des
sujets pour lesquels le collège
que le principe de liberté prime sur le
principe
d'intervention si on souhaite intervenir
le le le premier degré
c'est c'est une lettre qui est adressée
à
l'éditeur la tonalité peut peut changer
suivant la nature de ce qu'on l'autorité
a observé donc ce que je qualifierait de
la mise en garde c'est des c'est des
signalements que nous faisons à l'
sur des contenus qui ne caractérisent
pas un manquement au sens juridique du
terme mais sur lequel on estime qu'il
faut alerter
l'éditeur en lui disant attention vous
vous rapprochez vous rapprochez d'une
d'une ligne jaune les procédures prévu
par les textes donc c'est la mise en
demeure donc si un manquement est
constaté chez un éditeur au regard d'une
disposition législative ou
conventionnelle on prononce une mise en
demeure c'est un préalable absolu fixé
par la loi on peut pas sanctionner
directement un média on doit au
préalable prononcer une mise en demeure
sur une motivation très
précise et ce n'est qu'en cas de
réitération d'un manquement de même
nature que celle qui a donné lieu à la
mise en demeure j'insiste sur ce côté de
même nature qu'on peut rentrer en voie
de procédure de sanction sur laquelle je
vais je vais revenir c'est pour ça que
on peut être amené parfois à prononcer
plusieurs mises en demeure sur un même
éditeur et parfois on nous interroge en
dis mais vous l'avez déjà mis en demeure
donc pourquoi oui mais ça peut être sur
un autre motif il faut chaque fois que
ce soit ciblé et la mise en demeure bien
évidment susceptible de recours devant
devant le Conseil d'État donc il faut
que la motivation juridique soit soit
solide une fois qu'une mise en demeure a
été prononcée sur un motif précis et
qu'on constate un nouveau manquement de
même nature de la part de de la part de
l'éditeur le directeur général de
l'Autorité propriomotu donc c'est une
compétence qui n'est pas celle du
collège envoie le dossier de ce
manquement réitéré un rapporteur
indépendant qui est un membre du Conseil
d'État donc c'est le principe de la
séparation des poursuites et du jugement
donc ce rapporteur indépendant examine
le dossier on lui fournit tous les
éléments on lui fournit bien évidemment
la la mise en demeure préalable que nous
avons prononcé et au vu des éléments il
décide d'engager des poursuites ou pas
s'il décide d'engager des poursuites il
le fait suivant une procédure
contradictoire donc notification des
grief la chaîne mise en cause a au
minimum un mois pour répondre le
rapporteur indépendant analyse ensuite
le dossier fait rapport à l'autorité et
à ce moment-là le dossier revient entre
les mains du collège qui
convoque une séance qui est équivalente
à celle d'un tribunal donc on convoque
l'éditeur on l'entend on entend ses
conseil juridique on entend le
rapporteur indépendant et ensuite
l'autorité statut quelle est la GE des
sanctions c'est sousjac votre
question donc la loi prévoit toute une
panoplie donc le premier degré c'est la
publication d'un communiqué que
l'autorité peut imposer à l'éditeur
rédige lu impose fusion suivant des
modalités à l'autre bout de l'échelle la
plus grave c'est le retrait de
l'autorisation dans l'histoire de
l'autorité le retrait de l'autorisation
n'est intervenu qu'une fois comme vous
le savez c'était pour la chaîne dite
numéro
23 et comme vous le savez le Conseil
d'État a annulé la décision de
l'autorité et au milieu on
peut prononcer des sanctions financières
c'est l'outil que l'autorité utilise le
plus dans une limite qui est 4 % du
chiffre d'affaires de
l'éditeur plafond qui peut être porté à
5 % en cas de
récidive la sanction la plus importante
que nous ayons prononcé c'est cette
année comme vous le savez donc avec une
sanction de 3 3 million et demi d'euros
sur un éditeur précisément parce qu'on
considérait qu'on était dans un cas de
de récidif par rapport à des an à des
sanctions
précédentes la loi nous donne d'autres
facultés possibles interrompre un
programme suspendre un programme
raccourcir éventuellement l'autorisation
euh on peut
suspendre j'essie de pas oublier les
écrans
publicitaires aussi une faculté que nous
avons parfois utilisé qui est à double
tranchant je l'ai vécu le jour où j'ai
pris mes fonctions puisque une
précédente sanction du collège précédent
avait retenu cette formule elle a été
annulée là aussi par le Conseil d'État
et donc à ce moment-là l'éditeur nous a
demandé de devoir bien évidemment lui
rembourser le manque à gagner c'était
parement agréable pour un magistrat de
la Cour des comptes d'avoir cette
première décision à
prendre très rapidement monsieur le
Président est-ce que vous pouz juste
nous donner la différence entre les
sanctions possibles pour les éditeurs
privés et publics est-ce que ce sont les
mêmes sur la base des cahers des charges
pour pour le public ce sont les
mêmes on a appris récemment enfin dans
un
documentaire paru enfin diffusé il y a
quelques jours que un programme a pu
être en 13 ans mis en demeure 27 fois
est à partir de quand considère-t-on que
alors vous l'avez précisé il faut que la
mise en demeure porte soit de même
nature mais partir de quand d'une
certaine façon considèreon que l'espèce
de surcis que représente la mise en
demeure c'est
un alors il faut rappeler que dans la
loi actuelle la mise en demeure n'a une
durée de vie que de 5 ans si dans les 5
ans qui suivent la mise en demeure il ne
s'est rien passé d'autre la mise en
demeure tombe et donc le régulateur est
tenu de reprononcer une mise en demeur
et de
repartir de repartir à zéro si si je
puis dire
alors j'aimerais évoquer l'évolution des
des le contenu des conventions et
l'évolution des des conventions d'abord
sur le contenu les conventions
contiennent des des notions
euh assez générales et en même temps
très prescriptive euh comme le respect
de la dignité des personnes euh comme je
vous l'ai dit au début comment on
apprécie la qualité la question de la
dignité euh je peux vous donner
récemment un exemple euh de d'atteinte à
mon avis à la
dignité une personnalité publique tient
des des propos réputés ignobles ou à
l'égard d'une petite fille
euh certains pensent que l'information
justifie de diffuser cette image là
personnellement je considère qu'elle
porte atteinte à la dignité comment vous
faites-vous pour apprécier ce genre de
chos c'est bien évidemment à la fois la
partie la plus passionnante j'allais
dire de des missions qui nous sont
confiées mais en même temps la partie la
plus la plus difficile d'être
constamment dans cette balance entre
l'expression libre d'une d'un point de
vue d'une opinion d'une pensée je je
rappelle une fois encore que cette
liberté est très
vaste on a un
arrêt topique comme on dit de la Cour
européenne des droits de l'homme qui qui
rappelle que la liberté d'expression
c'est aussi des propos qui heurtent et
qui choquent c'est l'essence même de la
liberté de d'expression mais il y a des
limites très claires qui sont posées
dans la loi et notamment des
incriminations très claires qui sont
posés en terme d'atteinte à la dignité
de la de la personne pour reprendre la
question que que vous posez avec des
jurisprudences de la Cour de cassation
ou du Conseil d'État qui éclaire assez
nettement les cas de Figur sur lesqueles
cette incrimination peut peut
s'appliquer et donc à la lumière de
l'examen de la séquence de l'analyse de
la séquence euh ben le collège statut et
se
prononce voors et effectivement il peut
nous arriver
de d'avoir les les quatre diffamations
qui auquelles vous faites allusion dont
eux ne relèvent que du jeu judiciaire on
ne se prononce jamais en tant que tel
sur souvent on dit B le l'arcom
sanctionner tel animateur ou tel autre
j'insiste on sanctionne l'éditeur on
sanctionne pas la personne et on peut
avoir les deux chefs d'action ça m'est
arrivé moi-même dans l'année où j'ai
pris ma fonction à la fois que le
collège décide de sanctionner l'éditeur
mais en même temps de saisir le
procureur de la République en estimant
que au-delà de la responsabilité de
l'éditeur la personne qui avait prononcé
ses mots avait engagé sa responsabilité
sur le terrain
judiciaire
alors j'avais pas à l'esprit un cas de
diffamation mais ça c'est c'est égal la
démonstration vaut quand même
oui est-ce que vous pouvez nous
expliquer s'il y a un proc la procédure
de révision de discussions les échanges
qui existent entre les chaînes de
télévision et l'arcom pour
éventuellement modifier les
conventions alors la procédure
d'attribution donc je l'ai expliqué se
fait par voie d'appel d'appel à
candidature ce n'est pas le régulateur
qui fixe le cahier des charges on n'est
pas dans une logique identique à celle
d'un d'un appel d'offre sur un marché
public he où l'administration fixe la
prestation qu'elle attend de ceux qui
vont répondre à l'App la candidature là
les candidats sous réserve de des
dispositions qui sont posées par la loi
que j'ai rappelé dans mon propos
liminaire propose propose son projet
tout ça va se décliner dans une
convention l'un des intérêts de la
procédure et l'intérêt de la procédure
dans laquelle on s'engage aujourd'hui
c'est qu'on va repartir d'une feuille
blanche donc les autorisations
s'arrêtent en 2025 les 15 les 15
fréquences deviennent disponibles et
donc l'arcom remet en
candidature ces 15 c'est 15 fréquences
on va voir venir les candidats on
analysera on choisira ensuite tout ça se
décline dans des conventions et donc ces
procédures de renouvellement sont
l'occasion de revoir intégralement les
conventions c'est ce qui s'est passé
pour TF1 M6 j'imagine que vous allez
auditionner les
éditeurs je ne doute pas qu'il vous
feront part de leur de leur grief à tout
ce que nous avons pu rajouter nous-même
dans dans les conventions à l'occasion
de cette de cette réécriture nous venons
d'agréer il y a peu de temps le
changement de contrôle par une
commandite de la station Europe 1 la
convention d'EUR 1 a été revue à cette
occasion donc c'est des conventions qui
d'une part comme vous l'avez dit
reprennent des clauses de portée
générale et notamment des obligations
qui sont fixés par le législateur ou par
le l'exécutif par voie de règlement mais
c'est aussi des conventions qui
reprennent tous les engagements que
l'éditeur a pris devant l'autorité à la
fois par le dossier de
candidature mais aussi par ce qu'il dit
devant le collège à l'occasion de
l'audition publique et donc tout ça va
être transcrit au sein de cette
convention qui servira bien évidemment
de base c'est pas la seule mais c'est
une des bases pour les éventuelles
interventions du régulateur au titre
d'un manquement de
l'éditeur en cours de vie de
l'autorisation il est possible
d'apporter des
amédiations à la convention mais on ne
peut le faire qu'à la marge la
jurisprudence du Conseil d'État est
vraiment très claire sur ce point on ne
peut pas apporter de modification
substantielle précisément parce queil y
a une procédure d'appel à candidature
plusieurs candidats se sont présentés on
en a retenu un et donc si on modifie en
cours de route le format de la chaîne
par exemple celui qui n'a pas été retenu
serait enclin à dire mais bon c'est de
poid de mesure donc voilà la convention
c'est un moment important et c'est l'une
des raisons pour lesquelles on va lancer
dès
2024 la procédure parce que c'est une
procédure assez longue comme vous le
voyez dans les étapes que j'ai décrites
tout à l'heure et l'une des étapes
importantes c'est bien sûr la rédaction
de la convention et l'expérience en tout
cas celle que j'ai vécu au cours des 5
dernières années montre qu'il faut un
certain temps pour écrire cette
convention qui qui va jouer un rôle très
important ensuite dans la vie de de
l'autorisation et quand on ajuste ou
quand on réécrit ces ces convention bien
évidemment on prend en compte
euh tout ce que le le régulateur
l'avantage des
administrations là aussi c'est un vieux
fonctionnaire qui parle c'est qu'on a la
mémoire des choses et donc pendant la
vie d'une autorisation on a constaté on
a vu on a vu des évolutions et on en
tient compte dans
l'adaptation du média on tire les leçons
aussi de de l'expérience pour pour
ajuster les termes de ces
conventions alors à propos justement de
de ces changements
l'arcom ne s'est opposé finalement qu'à
deux reprises à des projets de de
vente tous les autres ont été autorisés
est-ce que vous pouvez nous expliquer
qu'est-ce qui a bloqué dans ces dans ces
à ces occasions là et qu'est-ce qui
finalement représente quelle garantie
avait pu être donné au par
par les acheteurs pour tous les
changements de contrôle et de
concentration alors peut-être pas tous
parce que j'imagine que la liste est un
peu longue sous sous mon mandat je n'ai
pas connu de cas de figure de ce type
donc ça ça ça remonte à des
périodes antérieures celle que j'ai en
tête mais je je découvre votre question
c'est la chaîne numéro 23 où
effectivement l'autorité avait accordé
une fréquence à cette à cette chaîne au
porteur de cette chaîne qui lui-même a
voulu
céder
sa sa société
euh et un dialogue s'est entamé
conformément à la loi puisque tout
changement de contrôle d'un éditeur est
soumis à l'agrément du régulateur ça
c'est des cas de figure que que j'ai pu
connaître mais là c'était le cas et les
informations qui ont été données au
régulateur à l'époque ENF je vais pas
rentrer dans les détails de l'affaire
qui a fait l'objet d'une commission
d'enquête de votre assemblée il y a y a
quelques années donc qui raconte tous
les tous les épisode et tous les
éléments du dossier le régulateur à
l'époque a estimé qu'il n'avait pas
suffis d'élément bon et ça abouti au
bout du compte au retrait de
l'autorisation cette décision a été
contestée par le titulaire de
l'autorisation le Conseil d'État lui a
donné raison et donc la session a pu se
faire au bout du compte c'est le groupe
qui est maintenant le groupe Altis à
l'époque celui dirigé à veille qui a
récupéré cette cette
autorisation j'ajoute que l'annulation
en question
c'est je ne saurais trop insister sous
le sur le contrôle du juge
l'annulation de la décision a exposé
l'autorité c'est aussi quelque chose que
j'ai découvert en prenant mes
fonctions un contentieux en
responsabilité et le titulaire de la
dite autorisation a demandé pas moinsune
indemnisation à hauteur de 20 millions
d'euros pour la décision et cette
affaire est aujourd'hui devant le
Conseil
d'État à propos des des contenus tout
simplement des des chaînes de télévision
on a l'impression que il y a une forme
d'homogénéité ou d'homogénéisation
progressive des des programmes est-ce
que vous est-ce que c'est une impression
que vous partagez d'abord est-ce que
vous l'avez objectivement observé et à
quoi vous
l'imputez al pour pour mêtre intéressé à
ces sujets pratiquement tout au long de
ma ma carrière en tout cas depuis une
quarantaine d'années
euh et quand je regarde la TNT qui s'est
déployé à partir des des années 2005
comme comme je le disais
euh je serais assez tenté de partager
votre
constat plus plusieurs choses ressortent
quand même quand on regarde
l'évolution d'abord le modèle de la TNT
payante est un modèle en attrition ne
reste plus aujourd'hui au tire de la TNT
payante que Canal Plus pas pas la
moindre et puis Paris première d'une
certaine façon mais toutes les autres
expériences de TNT payante ont
aujourd'hui disparu et quand on a fait
le renouvellement de l'autorisation de
Canal Plus en 2020 et qu'on a lancé
l'appel à candidature il n'y avait aucun
autre candidat que Canal Plus pour un
modèle de de TNT payante on verra ce qu'
encera avec l'appel à candidature à
venir mais on voit que ce modèle là déjà
a disparu ce qu'on peut comprendre en
même temps je pense que le développement
maintenant des plateformes de streaming
et des services de médias audiovisuel la
demande explique cette cette première
tendance la deuxième tendance c'est
qu'effectivement la TNT offrait d'un
côté des chaînes
généralistes de l'autre des chaînes
thématiques et et c'est vrai quand on
regarde les l'évolution des chaînes
thématiques on peut observer
effectivement une certaine tendance à à
la convergence ou à l'homogénéisation
des des programmes d'abord beaucoup de
ces chaînes thématiques sont rattachés à
des les chaînes premium celles qui sont
attattachées à TF1 et M6 notamment mais
on pourrait donner d'autres d'autres
exemples donc elles servent souvent à la
circulation des œuvres donc des choses
qu'on a vu à un moment on peut les
retrouver sur sur les autres et et
effectivement la la nature des des
lignes
éditoriales même même s'il y a
encore des dominantes je sais pas W9 une
dominante musicale conformément à sa
convention on voit bien une certaine
forme de rapprochement pourquoi cette
évolution pour moi incontestablement
elle est lié au modèle économique des
des chaînes
c'est le modèle publicitaire aujourd'hui
qui est sous-jacent pour les chaînes
privées la tendance est très nette elle
est connue pour la presse écrite elle
est maintenant marqué pour la radio avec
une baisse de la
ressource et une concurrence de format
par les plateformes de streaming je
pense sur radio musicale pour la
télévision les ressources publicitaires
sont grosso modo étales
aujourd'hui peu près 3
milliards plus ou moins d'une année sur
l'autre enfin c'est un moment où ces
acteurs pour les raisons que que j'ai
rapidement évoqué tout à l'heure sont
contraints à la fois de faire des
investissements
technologiques pour s'engager dans le
streaming et aller chercher les publics
là où ils sont et notamment les publics
les plus
jeunes ça coûte cher et et en même temps
d'investir dans les contenus pour
rivaliser avec la compétition toutes ces
plateformes de streaming elles
fonctionnent sur un principe
d'exclusivité
elles signe les artistes comme on
dit et donc il y a une inflation des
coûts de programme qui est incontestable
et donc les chaînes sont toutes engagés
à la fois dans cet investissement
technologique dans cet investissement
des contenus et dans un mouvement de
rationalisation de leur cût vous avez vu
que le groupe TF1 annoncé hier ou
avant-hier un un plan d'économie
substantiel
avec en même temps des investissements
sur sur le sur le streaming donc je
pense c'est voilà c'est c'est
l'évolution du modèle économique qui
impacte peu ou prou l'orientation de de
ces
médias avant de laisser la parole
peut-être à mes collègues je veux pas
monopoliser je voudrais évoquer le cas
particulier des des chaînes
d'information est-ce que le l'arcom fait
un un décompte de du temps consacré à
l'opinion et à l'information est-ce que
vous pouvez nous
donner le fruit de ces observations et
j'ajoute est-ce que vous ne pensez pas
que il faudra être à l'avenir plus
rigoureux dans la dans les conventions
pour distinguer information et
opinion merci monsieur le rapporteur
écoutez je ferai plusieurs plusieurs
constats si vous me permettez
d'abord le premier c'est une singularité
française d'avoir quatre chaînes
d'information permanentes je dis quatre
chaînes je pourrais rajouter d'une
certaine façon France
24 d'une certaine façon les chaînes
parlementaires qui contribuent aussi à
cette action mais on a quatre chaînes
une publique trois
privé je rappelle qu'à la date où nous
nous réunissons deux de ces chaînes sont
déficitaires
donc on a trois chaînes privées qui sont
en en concurrence frontale sur un même
marché
publicitaire situation qui est
probablement pas neutre
sur les choix
éditoriaux et en même temps sur la
structuration des programmes en matière
d'information vous le savez c'est une
chose d'envoyer des équipes de reportage
sur le
terrain en terme de coût çaen est une
autre d'organiser un débat avec quelques
éditorialistes sur sur un
plateau l'information elle peut prendre
des formes diverses naturellement et le
débat ça concourt aussi à
l'information mais c'est c'est sûr que
le régulateur sera certainement attentif
et c'est peut-être un sujet pour le
législateur aussi
euh à la place que l'information au sens
où nous l'entendons tous euh au sens
distinct de celui du débat peut tenir
sur une chaîne sur une chaîne
d'information sur ce sujet vous évoquez
du coup le rôle des éditorialistes vous
avez
l'arcom aurait entrepris en tout cas de
demander aux chaînes de décomter le
temps de parole
de certains éditorialistes est-ce que
désormais finalement le métier
d'éditorialiste c'est comparable avec
une fonction de
politique alors la loi de
86 est très claire elle elle là aussi
éclairé par la jurisprudence elle flèche
très clairement le pluralisme politique
dans une acception j'allis dire
classique du terme c'est-à-dire qu'elle
nous elle demande aux médias de
communiqu
au
régulateur la liste des personnalités
politiques qu'elles invitent les tempss
de parole de ces personnalités
politiques et le régulateur les vérifie
en période hors élection ce qu'on
appelle le pluralisme ordinaire nous
dressons le bilan de manière
trimestrielle pourquoi de façon
trimestrielle simplement parce que il y
a des médias qui font beaucoup
d'information il y en a d'autres qui en
font très peu et donc pouvoir équilibrer
les temps de paroes des formations
politiques le le le rythme triénal est
plus adapté en période électorale ce
contrôle est beaucoup plus resserré on
va rentrer dans bientôt dans la campagne
des des européennes on prendra une
délibération particulière sur le sujet
début début 24 et notre contrôle sera
naturellement plus plus étroit et comme
vous le savez par ailleurs nous
organisations les campagnes officielles
au moment de l'élection présidentielle
des élections
législatives aujourd'hui la loi ne
prévoit en aucune façon de comptabiliser
les temps de parole des éditorialistes
qui pour la plupart sont des
journalistes en aucune façon je ne
connais pas une démocratie aujourd'hui
on demande à une autorité administrative
de demander aux médias de leur
communiquer la liste des éditorialistes
qu'ils invitent sur leur plateau et les
temps de paroes en tout cas la loi n'est
pas rédigée comme ça et donc ce point ne
ressort pas en tant que tel du contrôle
de l'arcom sous réserve bien évidemment
que les expressions utilisées par les
uns ou par les autres se se conformment
se conforment à la loi
c'est vendant pour répondre autrement à
votre question je je le redis la liberté
éditoriale des chaînes
prévaut quel qu'elle soit quel que soit
ce média que soit public qui soit qui
soit privé le contrôle par l'arcom c'est
le pluralisme politique et bien
évidemment le respect des obligations
auquel l'éditeur est tenu et je veux
insister sur ce point parce que chaque
fois qu'on prononce une mise en demeure
chaque fois qu'on est sur une procédure
de sanction plusieurs qui sont en cours
d'instruction en ce moment des deux cas
de figure c'est la conviction assuré
qu'on est bien sur un manquement
caractérisé et une toute dernière
question vraiment pour ne pas lasser la
patience de mes collègues vous
m'expliquez vous nous expliquez
que le calcul du pluralisme est sur une
base trimestrielle est-ce que vous
étudiez ce pluralisme sur sur la base de
créneau horaire ou sur l'ensemble de la
programmation on prend on est on a été
amené à intervenir très clairement je je
comprends le sens de votre question on a
été amené à prononcer des mises en
demeure sur des médias qui s'aquittent
de leur obligation de pluralisme à des
horaires peu compatibles avec une vision
du pluralisme au sens où le législateur
l'entendait donc on peut pas s'acquiter
de son obligation de pluralisme en
diffusant telle ou telle famille
politique tel ou tel programme au milieu
de la nuit certains on fait nous les
avons mis en
demeure et bien évidemment ce serait un
motif de sanction en cas de
réitération merci monsieur le Président
merci monsieur le rapporteur je prie
bien sûr mes collègues d'excuser le le
temps des questions mais c'est vrai que
c'est important pour pour le rapporteur
d'en poser beaucoup parce que cette
audition est assez structurante je pense
pour la suite des travaux alors ce que
je vais vous proposer c'est de faire
question réponse c'est dire une question
et ensuite en tout cas un député une
député et puis réponse du président de
manière à avoir les réponses plus
précise possible par rapport à vos
questions dans l'ordre d'inscription je
commence par Monsieur es
queengx et oui je dégainé merci monsieur
le Président pour ces propos très
complets et vos explications euh je vais
faire court puisque le temps déjà été
relativement long donc je souhaitais
vous poser personnellement trois
questions euh premièrement depuis 4 ans
à la tête de l'institution eu
connaissance de fait ou de tentative
d'intervention comment y avez-vous
répondu deuxièmement certains sur nos
banqus critiqu la présence de certains
milliardaires dans la propriété des
chaînes privées TNT s'agit-il pas d'une
logique liée à l'économie des médias
privés euh et a
vu pour trouver son public ça demande
des moyens très importants aussi av pu
observer depuis votre présidence un
profil type des besoins financiers et
quantifier ses montants enfin
pensez-vous qu'il pensez-vous nécessaire
de revoir les règles de propriété des
chaînes par exemple d'abaisser les
seuils d'audience faut-il également
appliquer aux chaînes câblé
satellitaires les mêmes interdictions de
propriété par des personnes
extraeuropéennes que nous appliquons au
chîn TNT afin de limiter les ingérences
étrangères je
vouserci merci monsieur le député alors
intervention je suppose que le sens de
votre question c'est intervention
politique peut-être ou
non écoutez en tout cas moi je peux vous
donner mon expérience personnelle depuis
ans bien évidemment
c'est c'est mon propos l'autorité et
votre son président en tout cas n'a subi
aucune intervention au cours des 5
années qui se sont
écoulé y compris j'insiste également sur
ce point parce que j'ai encore vu un
article de presse sur ce sujet il y a
peu de temps au moment de la nomination
des responsables de l'audiovisuelle
publi puisque c'est une des compétences
qui nous revient c'est nous qui nommons
les présidents de l'UD publ c'est une
nomination qui se fait avec un vote à
bulletin
secret et donc le vote de chacun des
membres de l'Autorité est naturellement
naturellement libre j'ai j'ai des
interventions politiques d'une autre
nature de l'ensemble des familles
politiques que vous représentez ici
précisément au titre du pluralisme donc
c'est ça pour le coup très fréquent
qu'un président de parti qu'un
parlementaire écrivve à l'autorité en
exprimant son sentiment qui n'a pas
accès de manière équitable à tel Etel
médias qui n pas été invité depuis X
temps dans tel dans tel ou tel média
plutôt sur des formations politiques qui
ont une représentation relativement
limitée dans les assemblées
parlementaires ça c'est des choses
effectivement qu'on voit de façon
régulière et bien évidemment on regarde
ce qu'il en est si cette famille
politique a été traitée de façon
équitable ou pas et le cas échéant nous
nous sommes amenés à intervenir auprès
des médias je pense que cette règle du
pluralisme vous me posiez la question
monsieur le rapporteur par il y a tout
un il y a un courant de pensée qui
estime que ces règles sont obsolètes
aujourd'hui qui dans le monde des médias
tel qu'on le connaît aujourd'hui la
prolifération de l'offre la
prolifération de l'offre numérique qui
n'est pas soumise à ces obligations il
faudrait abandonner cette règle hormis
la période électorale ce qui est à peu
près ce qu'on retrouve en général dans
les démocraties notre système français
très particulier le fait de contrôler le
pluralisme tout au long de l'année c'est
vraiment une
singularité je pense que c'est l'une des
vertus tout de même du débat
démocratique équilibré en tout cas c'est
l'expérience que j'ai j'ai observé et on
voit bien aussi tel que fonctionnent les
médias les risques d'avoir des pics de
surreprésentation à un moment donné pour
une raison pour une autre li à
l'actualité il un positionnement
politique de tel ou tel et cette règle
du pluralisme est tout de même une corde
de rappel qui permet de rééquilibrer les
choses et de permettre à toutes les
forces politiques quel qu'elles soit
d'avoir un accès équilibré c'est très
critiqué par les médias très critiqué
par les rédaction qui nous considèr que
nous exerçons un contrôle tatillon mais
c'est la mission que nous confie que
nous confie que nous confie la loi les
les milliardaires dans les médias je
crois que c'est une histoire aussi
longue que l'histoire des des médias et
faut relire Balzac et les illusions les
illusions perdues pour voir que déjà
très tôt dans nos modèles de médias
cette question de l'argent
et des médias étaient très présentes je
parle pas du modèle américain c'est
quasi quasi
structurel ça coûte très cher de faire
de la
télévision porter un un média c'est
beaucoup d'argent avoir une très grande
rédaction professionnelle comme celle de
TF1 le service public vous voyez vous
votez les crédits qui sont consacrés au
service public vous voyez les masses
financières qui sont en jeu ça coûte
très cher de faire de la télévision
c'est beaucoup de savoir-faire beaucoup
de techniques des coups de diffusion
très importants des masses d'équipes de
personnel à rémunéré la production
audiovisuelle coûte cher et donc les
médias ont besoin d'être financés et je
pense qu'au cœur des états généraux de
l'information aujourd'hui la question
centrale c'est celle du modèle
économique de nosadia
comment veille-t-on à assurer pour notre
presse écrite pour nos radios pour nos
médias audiovisuel un modèle économique
qui résiste notamment à la concurrence
des acteurs du numérique notamment à
cette captation de la recette
publicitaire c'est trois acteurs
extraeuropéens qui mobilisent plus de 50
% de la ressource qui va au médias
Amazon ma notamment Google les
trois et donc si on n' pas un moment un
rééquilibre et bien le pluralisme des
médias sera menacé ça je pense qu'il
faut vraiment la question centrale
aujourd'hui c'est bien cellelà la presse
écrite qui est confrontée depuis très
nombreuses années la radio commenent à y
être confrontés les médias de télévision
y sont également confrontés donc cette
question elle est elle est vraiment
centrale les patrons de médias se sont
exprimés lors de la commission d'enquête
du Sénat sur la concentration dans les
médias beaucoup de patrons de de presse
ou médias audiovisuel ont souligné
qu'ils étaient quand même bien content
de trouver des financeurs ce qui est
important c'est c'est d'avoir un modèle
de financement qui assure le pluralisme
la pluralité des acteurs et d'avoir des
règles qui permettent de protéger de la
de se protéger de la concentration d'une
part et de garantir l'indépendance des
médias c'est sur ce point qu'il faut
effectivement être vigilant et et
attentif sur la propriété des chaînes
donc je pense que votre question c'est
probablement la règle des 20 % de
capitaux extraeuropéens donc c'est une
règle qui est appliquée au chaînes de de
la TNT comme vous le savez donc une
chaîne de la TNT ne peut pas avoir dans
le capital de l'éditeur plus de 20 % de
capitaux
extraeuropéens c'est une règle qui est
destinée à à protéger la souveraineté de
nos de nos éditeurs on peut considérer
qu'on regarde l'économie de marché de
façon générale c'est une règle qui est
aujourd'hui trop trop contraignante moi
je pense qu'on a un enjeu de
souveraineté sur nos médias audiovisuels
auquel il faut être attentif et que
cette règle garde son
sens merci Madame
lein merci monsieur le Président merci
monsieur le Président et merci à vous
trois pour votre présence et ces
échanges très riches alors euh deux
questions pour ma part une question sur
la place du groupe Boloré dans les dans
les chaînes qui sont en liste pour le
renouvellement en 2025 il y en a un
certain nombre de chaînes de ce groupe
notamment C news C8 et canal est-ce que
ça met pas ce Grou troupe dans une
position de de force finalement par
exemple on peut se demander si l'arcom
va vraiment avoir le choix de renouveler
ou pas la convention canal quand on
canal plus quand on voit euh l'utilité
pour le financement du cinéma français
enfin ça sa situation centrale dans le
financement du cinéma français est-ce
que ça daisse pas la possibilité au
groupe Boloré de de de de faire planer
une menace de de retrait de soutien au
cinéma français on est si jamais par
exemple C C8 ou C news à tout hasard
venait à à perdre leur agrément et du
coup ça interroge sur la la le choix qu'
a eu de donner à Canal plus de ne pas
donner un an de plus en fait pour éviter
justement que ce renouvellement a lieu
en même temps ça c'est ma première
question ma deuxième question vous vous
avez évoqué le processus de négociation
avec avec les éditeurs commencés en
septembre dernier et j'avoue c'est
peut-être par extériorité à votre
fonctionnement mais que ça ça interroge
en fait ce fonctionnement de de au fond
de négociation des des cahiers des
charges on entend parler parfois du fait
que que bah finalement il y aurait un
nég une négociation du cahier des
charges avec les personnes qui sont
ensuite susceptibles d'être d'êtreand
enfin qui sont ensuite candidate et ça
met un peu le ça ça semble mettre un peu
l'arcom en position à la fois de de
négociateur et de juges et les candidats
en position à la fois décrire les règles
du jeu enfin je sais pas si vous voyez
ce que je veux dire exactement mais
qu'est-ce que vous qu'est-ce que dans
les annonces publiques que vous allez
faire sur le résultat de ces échanges et
cetera comment qu'est-ce que vous
prévoyez de faire pour garantir au
public euh la certitude de votre
impartialité et de l'absence de rupture
d'égalité entre les candidats et entre
les candidats
merci merci beaucoup madame la députée
de ces deux ces deux
questions sur sur la première
famille de question ne m'enveillez pas
de de mes précautions de langage mais je
ne veux bien évidemment pas préjuger en
aucune façon de la procédure qui va qui
va se dérouler et je ne voudrais pas me
me départir d'une façon d'une autre de
l'impartialité à laquelle je suis tenu
et si je dis des rogets ce serait un
motif d'annulation pure et simple de la
procédure que nous allons conduire donc
je je ne porterai pas de jugement ou de
qualificatif sur tel ou tel médiia pour
pour les raisons de droit que je viens
d'évoquer de deux ou trois remarques
quand même par rapport à votre votre
question dont je comprends bien le le
sens la première sur la durée des
autorisations donc la loi fixe
simplement des durées maximum 10ant à la
suite de la procédure d'appel à
candidature et ensuite un renouvellement
possible sans appel à candidature pour 5
ans donc là on est dans le cas de figure
on repart à zéro les autorisations
arrivent complètement à leur terme et
donc les autorisations que nous allons
délivrer peuvent aller jusqu'à une durée
maximale de 10 ans c'est une durée
maximale l'éditeur peut tout à fait
souhaiter avoir une durée une durée
moindre
l'entreprise que vous avez que vous avez
évoqué est une entreprise je pense que
vous l'auditionnerez donc elle
l'expliquera sûrement plus
talentueusement que moi est une
entreprise qui a complètement changé de
de
modèle le canal plus d'aujourd'hui n'a
rien à voir au canal plus d'hier c'est
aujourd'hui pour l'essentiel une
plateforme numérique my
canal c'est un acteur qui ne prend plus
d'abonnés sur la TNT payante déjà depuis
depuis quelques temps hein il est
toujours présent sur la TNT payante mais
il ne prend plus d'abonnés quand on
s'abonne à Canal on s'abonne à la à la à
la plateforme euh et donc le nombre
d'abonnés TNT a beaucoup beaucoup
diminué pour cette pour cet éditeur et
donc la question de son maintien est une
question qui est un peu récurrente au
sein de ce ce groupe je je veux pas une
fois encore ils s'expliqueront devant
devant vous en temps en temps et heur je
pense euh la question du maintien sur la
TNT se peut se poser parce que la TNT a
beaucoup d'avantage mais la TNT a un
coût la TNT oblige l'éditeur à couvrir
au minimum 95 % du territoire donc ça
suppose de rémunérer le diffuseur TDF
c'est un coût de diffusion qui est qui
est élevé sur l'ensemble du territoire
pour accéder à l'ensemble des zones y
compris en l'occurrence pour une chaîne
payante dans des zones où elle n'a pas
d'abonnés et donc elle peut légitimement
se poser la question économiquement
est-ce que ça vaut encore le coup ou pas
que je sois présent sur la terte
prière première remarque explique qu'ils
aient souhaité avoir des durées des
durées plus courtes mais une fois encore
ce sera à eux de de le dire devant vous
deuxème remarque s'agissant du
financement du cinéma bien évidemment
c'est une entreprise qui joue un rôle
central c'est le premier financeur du
cinéma 200 million d'euros par an dans
l'accord actuel avec les professionnels
du cinéma accord qui arrive à échéance
en 2000 en 2024 dont les les premières
discussions viennent viennent de
commencer euh le point que je veux
souligner devant vous par rapport à
votre question c'est que les décrets
production qui ont été revus en
2021 fixe les obligations et des
obligations de même nature quel que soit
le mode de
diffusion donc les obligations qui
pèsent sur les éditeurs en TNT valent
pour une diffusion en câble ou en
satellite de même qu'elle valent pour
une une diffusion sous forme sous forme
de SMAD donc même s'ils
abandonnent TNT et qui se concentre sur
une diffusion capsate comme on dit il
serait soumis à un régime d'obligation
de même nature et grosso modo de de même
de même
montant sur les négociations d'abord je
je reprécise quand même par rapport à
votre intervention je redis nous fixons
pas de cahier des charges on lance un
appel à candidature l'appel à
candidature son contenu est fixé par la
loi j'ai rappelé les les les items que
doit comporter l'appel à candidature
après les candidats donc donc vous avez
utilisé l'expression les négociations
que vous avez engagé depuis septembre on
a engagé aucune négociation depuis
septembre pour l'instant on a fait une
consultation publique on a dit au marché
au secteurs aux acteurs à qui veut il y
a 15 autorisations qui arrivent à
chéance on a posé toute une série de
questions à l'occasion de cette
consultation publique pour recueillir
les impressions des uns et des autres
ensuite on réalise notre étude d'impact
qui est à finalité économique et vous en
aurez communication très prochainement
vous verrez c'est un un document
vraiment très très riche on lance
l'appel à candidature les candidats vont
y répondre vont nous faire des
propositions des projets vont les
défendre ensuite en audition son
publique si on les retient et ce n'est
qu'après qu'on rentrera dans une phase
de mise au point des conventions et la
mise au point des convention c'est pas
une négociation c'est le régulateur qui
fixe la convention et cette convention
elle prend en compte les engagement que
l'éditeur a pris devant nous donc tout
ce qu'il dit dans son dossier de
candidature tout ce qu'il va dire au
moment des aud i vont être consigné noir
sur blanc dans la convention et ensuite
effectivement on sera les les garant de
l'application de cette convention
j'ajoute que pendant toute cette phase
de
procédure les membres du collège se
tiennent à distance des éditeurs bien
évidemment il y a pas de rencontre
hormis bien évidment les services qui
peuvent continuer à dialoguer avec les
entreprise s'il y a un sujet technique
ou d'ordre administratif mais il y a une
règle partialité qui s'impose pour tous
les membres et donc c'est une période
pendant laquelle une fois que l'appel à
candidature sera lancé les membres se
tiendront se tiendront à distance donc
non on n'est pas jugé parti on choisit
le candidat et ensuite bien
évidemment on veille à l'application et
vraiment je veux insister sur le fait de
la très grande attention que l'autorité
porte à la mise en uvre de ces règles je
je je sais bien je vois bien les
interpellations
quotidiennes euh je tweite de façon
modérée pour ce qui me concerne mais ça
m'arrive de regarder cette plateforme ne
serait-ce qu'au titre de nos de nos
compétences je vois bien les
interpellations quotidiennes qui
peuvent le droit c'est le droit au
regarde d'une liberté publique
fondamentale le droit est
particulièrement strict et je pense que
c'est l'honneur et la responsabilité de
l'autorité de l'utiliser voilà dans un
cadre qui est très balisé pour nous
alors on peut considérer qu'onintervient
pas assez certains trouvent qu'on
intervient trop je pense que cette
double critique veut probablement dire
qu'on est sur une ligne de crête
raisonnable merci je donne la parole à
Madame t poon et ensuite ce sera
monsieur
Caron merci beaucoup monsieur le
Président Monsieur le Président merci
infiniment pour tous ces ces éléments
qui vont nourir notre notre réflexion
j'aurais une question sur
les je dis dirais les les critères de
choix que la loi vous impose qui sont
des critères à la fois précis mais à la
fois quand même qui peuvent faire
l'objet d'une forme de d'interprétation
ou de de travail de de définition vous
avez évoqué l'intérêt pour le public
dans un premier temps et l'impératif de
pluralisme dans un second temps et
expliquer parallèlement que le
pluralisme autant au terme de la loi
était uniquement le pluralisme politique
de la parole politique de responsable
politique identifié comme tel mais ne
peut-on avoir une une vision plus large
de l'intérêt du public et intégrer une
forme de pluralisme plus large dans
l'intérêt du public je m'explique quand
vous aurez à
déterminer quels seront les les les
tenants des autorisations pour 15
chaînes différentes euh étant donné que
c'est difficile de rentrer dans dans les
lignes éditoriales et que vous vous y
refusez et que c'est normal puisqueon
est dans le cadre de liberté de la
presse ne pensez-vous pas que dans le
casadre de le choix de ce bouquet de 15
chaînes il y aurait nécessité à garantir
une pluralité de lignes éditorial pour
faire en sorte d'éviter d'avoir des
chaînes d'information qui ont une ligne
éditoriale très claire une ligne
éditoriale d'extrême droite et
finalement en face à côté
euh et bien euh pas de pas de pendant
pas de correspondant est-ce que ça ce
n'est pas un problème d' pour l'intérêt
du public en d'autres terme euh
finalement et comme vous l'avez dit
vous-même il est difficile de trouver
des acteurs qui euh qui puissent
répondre aux obligations financière euh
de euh de la construction d'une chaîne
de télévision euh de de tout ce que ça
requiert en terme d'investissement donc
plutôt que de se dire est-ce qu'il
faudrait pas une pluralité dans le dans
un bouquet comme les oblige la loi sur
les kiosques puisqu'on doit avoir tous
les toutes les sensibilités toutes les
familles politiques ou des familles de
pensée qui sont représenté dans un
kiosque est visible pour toutes et tous
mais c'est difficile pour une chaîne de
télévision puisqu'il faudrait des
milliardaires qui soi en situation de de
défendre des lignes politiques et des
lignes éditoriales très différentes je
dis politique non au sens partisan mais
au sens d'une vision globale de la
société est-ce qu'il ne faudrait pas
comprendre cet intérêt pour le public au
sens d'une pluralité obligatoire au sein
des chaînes et qui ne se confondent pas
avec une vision stricte du pluralisme au
sens politique mais d'une vision plus
globale euh en terme de famille de
pensée d'association de vision euh qui
permettraiit de garantir d'éviter que ne
soit capté une chaîne TNT qui est donc
quand même une chaîne publique euh par
une orientation politique qui par
ailleurs a été on le sait extrêmement
partisane puisqu'elle a promu un futur
candidat à l' élection
présidentielle merci madame la
députée moi je je je redis ici que je ne
porterai aucun qualificatif sur aucune
chaîne de télévision pour les
raisons dont je me suis dont je me suis
expliqué l'intérêt du public vous avez
raison l'intérêt public il est il est
large ma titre personnel j'ai aussi un
intérêt en tant que en tant que
téléspectateur comme comme tout un comme
tout un
chacun la loi elle flèche assez
précisément d'abord un pluralisme ce
qu'on appelle le pluralisme externe
c'est-à-dire avoir une pluralité
d'opérateurs ça c'est vraiment
le m'interroger monsieur le Président
tout à l'heure sur le modèle de
régulation français vraiment la la ligne
fil rouge de cette régulation le fil
rouge de la loi de 86 c'est ce thème du
c'est ce thème du pluralisme c'est celui
qui guide l'essentiel l'essentiel de ce
du cadre qu'on met qu'on met en œuvre
donc l'un des critères d'appréciation
premier ça va être effectivement d'avoir
autant que possible je dis bien autant
que possible parce que il faut avoir des
candidats
euh la télévision je le disais tout à
l'heure coûte cher on verra qui sera
candidat l'année prochaine moi je peux
pas
préjuger euh de de qui se portera
candidat sur les sur les sur les
fréquences même si j'ai quelques petites
idées quand même sur le sur le sujet
donc l'un des premiers critères
d'appréciation pour nous ça sera
effectivement de faire en sorte qu'il
ait une pluralité d'acteurs parce que le
pluralisme au sens où vous l'exprimez
madame la députée c'est bien sûr aussi
la pluralité des acteurs c'est ça qui
garantit un modèle de médias div
diversifié
euh la pluralité c'est c'est aussi
l'intérêt du public au sens de la
pluralité des programmes de la nature
des programmes qui nous sont offerts ne
pas avoir que des chaînes d'infos ne pas
avoir que des chaînes musicales ne pas
avoir que des chaînes cinéma mais avoir
un horizon un horizon le plus large le
plus large
possible porter une appréciation sur une
ligne
éditoriale c'est autre chose
et on est là vraiment au cœur du
principe constitutionnel de liberté de
communication c'est pas l'arcom qui a
vocation à déterminer la ligne
éditoriale d'un média on peut penser ce
qu'on veut j'ai entendu vos vos points
de vue je je les connais nous avons
l'occasion d'échanger à plusieurs
reprises sur ces sur ces questions donc
je je connais vos vos convictions
l'arcom ne peut-être juge en tout cas
c'est comme ça que la loi est écrite
aujourd'hui que des manquements que
l'éditeur peut commettre dans le cadre
de l'expression de saline éditorial donc
on entend ce qui se dit sur ces médias
et le ce auquel vous avez pu faire
allusion euh l'autorité a été amenée à
prononcer à plusieurs reprises non
seulement des mises en demeure mais
aussi des mais aussi des des sanctions
en tout cas dans
notre dans notre approche hein une faut
encore sans sans préjuger c'est critère
de la diversité des opérateurs eux-même
pour éviter un phénomène de
concentration qui qui lui-même est cadré
par la loi d'ailleurs puisqu'on peut pas
détenir plus d'un certain nombre
d'autorisations mais la
pluralité l'intérêt du public au sens de
la diversité des
programmes et si josais pour reprendre
une expression qu'on utilisait dans ma
jeunesse pour ceux qui suivaient ces
sujets le mieux disant
culturel expression qui s un peu usée au
fil du temps mais qui garde quand même
tout son sens et sa portée seront
présents très certainement dans dans les
critères d'appréciation du du régulateur
j'ajoute parce que cette question m'a
pas été explicitement
posée que bien évidemment parmi les
critères d'appréciation du
régulateur le respect par un éditeur
sortant de ces
obligation fait fait partie des éléments
d'appréciation du régulateur ce n'est
pas le seul critèr bien
évidemment les critères prioritaires je
les ai rappelés mais celui-ci
fait partie des critères d'appréciation
du du régulateur semit important de de
le dire au regard de de la mission de
votre
commission merci Monsieur
Caron merci monsieur le Président merci
monsieur le Président de l'arcom ben ma
question va être un peu un prolongement
de votre dernière réponse puisqu'elle va
porter spécifiquement sur le cas
news et sur la convention qui qui lit
cette chaîne au CSA et donc à l'arcom
dans cette convention on lit des tas de
choses intéressantes qui représentent en
fait les obligations de la chaîne dans
ce qu'elle doit diffuser dans la manière
dont elle doit maîtriser son antenne
alors pardonnez-moi si je vais
peut-êtreêtre un petit peu long mais je
suis obligé si si on veut que la
question et notre échange est un intérêt
article 231 l'éditeur assure le
pluralisme de l'expression des courants
de pensées et d'opinion pluralisme sur
cette chaîne de fait n'est pas respecté
puisque c news est régulièrement appelé
à l'ordre fonctionné même par votre
autorité et il y a une étude qui a été
menée par le sémiologue François Jost
qui a étudié en détail cette chaîne et
qui a montré que les invités de droite
et d'extrême droite représentent 78 %
des invités en tout cas c'était le cas
en 2022 et la réalité on est obligé de
de le reconnaître c'est que cette chaîne
n'est plus une chaîne
d'information c'est devenue une chaîne
militante qui promeut un projet
idéologique un projet d'extrême droite
avec une préférence pour le le spectre
d'extrême droite zemourien Zemour dont
la chaîne a d'ailleurs assuré la
promotion dans le lancement de sa
campagne pour la présidentielle et donc
la réalité factuelle personne ici pourra
je pense en disconvenir c'est que cette
chaîne ressasse toujours les mêmes
thèmes les mêmes
obsessions souvent dirigé d'ailleurs
contre les musulmans contre
l'immigration et donc on est extrêmement
loin du pluralisme de l'expression des
courantes pensé des opinion article 232
l'éditeur veille dans son programme à
respecter les différentes sensibilités
politiques culturelles et religieuses du
public l'éditeur veille également à ne
pas encourager les comportements
discriminatoires au raison de la race de
l'origine du sexe de l'orientation
sexuelle de la religion ou de la
nationalité l'éditeur s'engage également
à lutter contre les discriminations en
prendre en considération dans la
représentation à l'antenne la diversité
des origines et des cultures là encore
ces news a été rappelé à l'ordre
tellement de fois même été condamné pour
ça je prends un exemple pour ceux qui
nous écoutent parce que il y a des gens
qui nous écoutent et qui sont intéressés
par nos échanges oui Éric Zemour Éric
Zemour encore lui qui peut dire
tranquillement sur l'antenne enfin pas
tranquillement puisqu'il sera contamné
pour ça les migrants mineurs isolés sont
tous des voleurs des assassins des
violeurs et je le répète les musulmans
c'est la cible quotidienne de ces news
obligation de contenu article 311 le
service est consacré à l'information il
offre un programme réactualisé en temps
réel couvrant tous les domaines de
l'actualité cette obligation n'est pas
non plus couverte n'est pas respectée
euh puisque c news est devenu une chaîne
de commentair et non plus une chaîne de
présentation des faits comme devraitêtre
une chaîne d'information même si le
commentaire a sa place sur une chaîne
d'info et je suis bien placé pour le
savoir puisque j'ai travaillé pour
l'ancêtre de ces news à l'époque où
cette chaîne faisait vraiment de
l'information et donc si on reprend
toujours l'étude menée par François Jost
et bien on constate que l'information
strict auinsu comme énonciation des
faits occupe seulement 13 % du temps
d'antenne sur les tranches étudi et
j'ajouteraiis qu'on trouve des choses
très curieuses également sur ces
news des choses qui al pour le coup
n'ont aucun rapport avec l'information
avec le factuel par exemple une émission
qui s'appelle enquête d'esprit qui est
une émission de militantisme catholique
radical avec par exemple le 2 octobre
2022 une émission intitulée ang démon le
vrai combat et on a pu entendre le
présentateur dire le plus sérieusement
du monde comme si c'était vraiment une
information à prendre extrêmement au
sérieux comme une information venue du
Proche Orient une information politique
quelconque c'est une réalité plus
sournoise que tous les virus plus
dangereuse que toutes les épidémie plus
contagieuse aussi que toutes les
infections cette réalité ce sont les
forces du Mal elles étendent leur
pouvoir dans toutes les sphères de la
société mais nous avons un allié
l'archange Saint-Michel comment lutter
contre le mal avec les armes de la foi
c'est le thème de cette émission
aujourd'hui il faudra qu'on m'explique
le rapport avec de
l'information donc je ne voudrais pas
monopoliser la parole je crois que vous
avez bien compris le sens de mon propos
et je crois que vous avez été alerté
vous même à de nombreuses reprises sur
le cass news même si je comprends bien
et je vous ai bien entendu
euh je comprends bien que vous ne
puissiez pas aujourd'hui porter un
jugement définitif sur l'avenir de ces
news quand même ces éléments que je
livre aujourd'hui non pas à votre
connaissance mais que je RPP appel à
votre mémoire ces éléments est-ce qu'il
vous pose pas quand même problème au
regard des obligations conventionnelles
hein de de de la chaîne et est-ce que la
question du retrait de son autorisation
donc le retrait de la fréquence au
groupe Boloré avec le projet actuel
est-ce que cette question est une
question
pertinente merci monsieur le député
Caron je crois que je vous ai bien
compris en effet
euh j'ai j'ai lu l'étude à laquelle vous
vous avez fait vous avez fait allusion
que personnellement trouvaé très
vraiment très très intéressante et je
regarde de façon
général les points de vue des des
universitaires avec lesquels nous avons
d'ailleurs des liens des liens réguliers
euh alors c'est vrai que c'est une
mesure du pluralisme qui est différente
de celle qu'on opère hein c'est donc il
a il y a un peu une
différence méthodologique
la la lecture que nous faisons de la loi
de
86 je l'ai dit tout à l'heure c'est une
lecture qui nous amène et qui amène à
demander aux médias audiovisuels de
comptabiliser les personnalités
politiques vous quand vous êtes sur un
plateau de télévision donc tous les tous
les élus bien évidemment tous les
personnalités qui sont engagé dans un
parti politique qui sont vraiment
explicitement dans l'action politique
dans le combat
politique mais on va pas au-delà parce
que la loi n'est pas écrite comme
ça je pense que ce serait très difficile
de l'écrire je vois pas bien comment on
écrirait d'aller au-delà dans la
comptabilisation notamment des
éditorialistes le rapporteur posa posé
la question tout à l'heure je pense
qu'au regard du principe de
liberté ce serait ce serait très très
problématique et donc la différence
effectivement qu'on a nous dans les
chiffres avec que le sémiologue que vous
évoquez tout à l'heure c'est c'est ça
c'est que c'est une modalité de contrôle
du pluralisme alors peut-être que nous
avons tort mais en tout cas on le fait
dans le cadre de la loi tel qu'il est
tel qu'il est elle est elle est rédigée
actuellement et et ma conviction c'est
qu'il faut pas aller au-delà je vous le
dis très simplement je pense je vous le
dis vraiment tout à fait entre nous je
pense qu'on est rentré dans une période
euh où ce thème de la liberté
château-billant l'a écrit beaucoup mieux
mieux que moi sans la liberté il n'y a
rien dans le monde la défense de cette
liberté quand on regarde les mouvements
généraux d'opinion de par le monde c'est
une thématique qui mérite aujourd'hui
beaucoup beaucoup d'attention et quand
on commence à brider la liberté on sait
où on commence on sait pas bien où on
finit donc je pense qu'il faut faire
très attention là-dessus c'est déjà une
singularité française de comptabilité le
pluralisme politique tout au long de
l'année de la part des médias aller
au-delà je pense que
constitutionnellement ce serait très
compliqué mais je suis prêt à avoir des
tentatives législatives sur ce point si
si vous estimez qu'il faut faire
modifier la Loi sur ce point sur les
autres points mais je suis vraiment très
clair avec vous des manquements
caractérisés à la loi et cette chaîne en
a commis amène le le régulateur à
intervenir dans les
conditions qui sont que j'ai eu
l'occasion d'évoquer tout à l'heure que
ce soit la mise en
demeure il y a encore des procédures qui
sont en cours d'instruction en ce moment
sur lesquel je peut pas préjuger mais
pas exclu que le régulateur soit soit
amené à intervenir euh vous évoquez un
éditorialiste qui était encore un
éditorialiste je je rappelle que
l'autorité pour la première fois a
sanctionné une chaîne d'information
cette chaîne-elà à laquelle vous avez
fait allusion à une auteur qui à
l'époque était sans précédent on peut
considérer que c'était pas assez mais à
l'époque c'était sans précédent regarde
l'histoire de de de l'autorité
euh voilà alors la fin de autorisation
vous avez évoqué mais la fin de
l'autorisation elle arrive qu'est-ce qui
se passera après je vous renvoie mes
propos précédent je ne peux pas préjuger
de la suite du
film je vais quand même me permettre
d'insister un petit peu je je je
comprends votre devoir de réserve mais
tout de même je crois que dans toutes
les chaînes de la TNT c'est la seule qui
présente les particularités que je viens
de vous
décrire franchement peut-être un petit
peu plus d'engagement ce matin dans
votre réponse alors je comment on
pourrait trouver les mots qui permettrai
de bien comprendre le fond de votre
pensée parce que je peux pas croire que
vous n'ayez pas d'opinion
d'avis sur ce sujet peut-être que vous
pvez répondre à cette question est-ce
que oui ou non les fait que je viens de
rappeler mérite qu'on s'interroge très
sérieusement sur le renouvellement de
cette autorisation est-ce que cette
interrogation vous la partagez avec moi
is monsieur le député je crois avoir
répondu à votre
question non pas chacun son rôle je
pense qu' est a ici pour avoir des
discours de vérité c'est
intéressant c'est ici je pense on doit
essayer d'avoir des débat très poussés
constructif monsieur Jean-Jacques
Gautier merci Président je voudrais
revenir sur les les difficultés qui ont
été aborder pour modifier des
conventions avant le renouvellement vous
avez évoqué d'ailleurs les procédures
d'appel d'offre préalable qui qui qui
encadre et qui fait qu'on ne peut
modifier ces conventions qu'à la marge
mais ces conventions on vous l'avz
rappeler une durée maximale de de 10 ans
et en 10 ans le paysage audiovisuel peut
changer considérablement que ce soit au
niveau des usage au niveau des
technologies on on nécoute plus
aujourd'hui la musique comme on
l'écoutait il y a 10 ans il y a il y a
des acteurs aujourd'hui qui n'était pas
là il y a 10 ans et le marché
publicitaire aujourd'hui n'est plus le
même que ce qu'il était il y a 10 ans
donc cette rigidité n'est-elle pas un
risque pour certains acteurs notamment
pour les chaînes privées pour pour
s'adapter pour faire preuve de
réactivité pour augmenter leur audience
afin de
garantir vous en avez parlé leur modèle
économique qui est la condition même du
du pluralisme et deuxème question
sous-jacente ne voyez-vous pas n'y a-il
pas aussi un risque d'asymétrie entre
les acteurs de l'audiovisuel public et
les chaînes privées quand on regarde les
comes quand quand on les a d'ailleurs
les a on encore pas les les futurs comes
mais ce sont des documents finalement
assez légers une dizaine de pages par
rapport à ces conventions vous avez
rappelé qui sont donc à la fois très
lourdes très rigides et qui font parfois
plusieurs centaines de PES donc n'y
a-t-il pas là un frein pour les chaînes
privées et un risque d'asymétrie entre
les différents acteurs publics et
privé merci monsieur le député j'ai
l'occasion de m'exprimer devant la
commission des affaires culturelles de
de l'Assemblée dans celle du Sénat hier
puis souvent publiquement donc vous
connaissez mes mes convictions donc vous
serez pas surpris par ma
réponse je pense vraiment pour suivre ce
paysage de très près depuis une
quarantaine d'années je pense qu'on est
vraiment dans une phase de mutation le
mot est un peu galvodé j'ai employé
moimême le mot de de révolution en tout
une phase de transformation très très
rapide du du secteur qui exige de la
part des pouvoirs publics et je me mets
bien évidemment en tant que président de
l'Autorité dans cette catégorie des
pouvoirs publics qui exige une grande
attention et et je salue d'ailleurs les
initiatives du Parlement parce que je
note que l'Assemblée nationale par les
travaux qu'elle a conduit y compris ceux
que vous avez conduit monsieur le
Président et et vous-même monsieur le
député sur l'audiovisuel public ou les
travaux que le Sénat a conduit c'est une
période où il faut être très attentif au
devenir de nos acteurs qu'ils soient
public ou privés ils sont confrontés à
une période de grande transformation
leur modèle que est très sérieusement
interrogé aujourd'hui et on peut
disserter à l'infini sur les vertus du
pluralisme si on n'assure pas un modèle
économique péren à ces acteurs là et
bien c'est la question du pluralisme qui
sera elle intrinsèquement posé donc il
faut qu'on soit attentif et dans cette
vigilance à avoir je je l'ai dit tout à
l'heure je le redis ici avec force les
asymétries pour
employer euh un mot un peu
technocratique entre les acteurs du
numérique et les acteurs traditionnels
régulés encadré contrôl très étroitement
corpus juridique applicable à nos
acteurs traditionnels vous avez fait
allusion il il est extrêmement dense et
les règles
euh je sais même pas si le mot est juste
qui s'applique aux acteurs du du
numérique la symétrie entre les deux la
la différence de situation l'inégalité
de situation entre les deux et est très
CLA en matière de réglementation sur la
publicité vous y avez fait allusion
c'est
ostensible on voit bien la façon dont
dont les acteurs du numérique captent de
façon croissante cette cette ressource
donc oui il faut être en accompagnement
oui il faut ouvrir des réflexions qui
nous paraissaient peut-être inopportunes
jusqu'à maintenant mais si on veut
sauvegarder nos acteurs si on veut avoir
des grands médias avec des rédactions
professionnelles qui soient à même de
nous assurer une information rigoureuse
pluraliste honnête euh ça suppose d'être
très vigilant sur le sur le modèle
économique et bien évidemment le service
public ne peut pas être étranger à ces
mouvements ça ça va s'en dire je me suis
souvent exprimé sur le sur le sujet un
service public fort et le service public
joue un rôle central dans l'équilibre du
paysage c'est 30 % des audiences c'est
15000 salariés il jouent un rôle central
sur le financement de la production il
jou un rôle central pour l'information
pour le rayonnement de la France à
l'étranger un service public fort c'est
un service bien financé avec une
ressource je le redis ici qui soit une
ressource affectée vous connaissez mes
positions monsieur le monsieur le
Président et et j'espère que le
dispositif de financement qui prévaut
pour l'instant après la suppression de
la de la contribution à l'udiovisuelle
publique d'une fraction de de TVA pourra
perdurer c'est très important d'avoir un
financement qui a garanti l'indépendance
de notre audiovisuel public et et un
niveau de financement à la hauteur de
des missions qu'on lui confie c'est un
service public bien financé c'est un
service public aussi qui rassemble ses
forces il est aujourd'hui engagé dans
des dans des mouvements importants pour
approcher France France 3 notamment du
réseau de de France Bleue ou pour donner
à France Info puisque plusieurs d'entre
vous m'ont interrogé sur les chaînes
d'information je suis convaincu qu'il
peut y avoir une chaîne d'information du
service public qui occupe une vraie
place en terme d'audience et on peut pas
se satisfaire je mets pas du tout en
cause naturellement les équipes de
France Info qui font très bien leur
métier mais on peut pas se satisfaire du
taux d'audience actuel à 08 09 comparé
aux chaînes privées je suis sûr que le
service public a une carte à jouer mais
ça passera très probablement par une
réflexion euh
euh sur la bonne gouvernance euh de pour
le pilotage de ces projets pour pouvoir
donner à France Info une vraie et bonne
dynamique pour pouvoir donner au projet
de rapprenochement France 3 France Bleue
toute la force toute la force qu'il doit
avoir donc j'espère avoir répondu
répondu à votre question s'agissant des
obligations alors je je je je sais bien
le discours que l'association des
chaînes privées qui se manifeste souvent
auprès de moi ontionn les représentants
de TF1 encore peu de temps peuvent
porter à l'égard du à l'égard du service
public le service public a beaucoup
d'obligations il suffit de de lire son
cahier des charges ce que nous faisons
régulièrement puisqu'on donne un avis
chaque année sur l'exécution des
contrats d'objectifs et sur le respect
du cahier des charges le service public
a une pluralité de mission une intensité
de mission qui qu'on ne peut pas qu'on
ne peut pas sous-estimer donc je je je
comprends je ne suis pas surpris que
certains acteurs du privé se plaainent
des conventions très dan que nous leur
imposons à l'occasion des
renouvellements d'autorisation mais
d'abord on fait notre métier et je pense
que le service public a lui aussi ses
obligations donc
voilà chacun chacun est à la bonne à la
bonne
enseille merci monsieur le Président je
précise d'ailleurs que Monsieur jus dont
on a parlé des des études tout à l'heure
sera reçu à 15h30 par notre commission
d'enquête il me reste j'ai trois
demandes de prise de parole à ce stade
monsieur GED madame et Monsieur de
Monsieur Gad à vous merci monsieur le
Président Monsieur le Président de
l'arcom
h dans les limites de ce que vous pouvez
nous dire vous avons bien compris le
cahier des charges j'ai j'ai deux
questions d'abord et sous le couvert du
du président du rapporteur je pense que
il serait utile pour nous d'avoir un un
bilan des sanctions qui ont été prononcé
j'imagine que ça fait partie des des
éléments que vous avez sollicité euh
auprès de auprès de l'arcom pour chacune
des des chaînes concernées pour
lesquelles un renouvellement va être
demander d'autant plus et merci de nous
le confirmer que euh est-ce que c'est un
élément qui sera pris en compte vous
vous dites on va regarder le bilan
l'expérience euh le respect des
conventions donc euh je sais pas s'il y
a une grille de notation enfin je sais
pas comment les choses s'objectivent euh
mais j'imagine que vous allez euh
attester de l'ampleur des sanctions qui
ont été prises par les les les unes et
enfin pour les les unes et les autres
pour les différentes chaînes je lisais
sur le rapport d'activité que l'année
dernière en 2022 vous avez prononcé 19
mises en demeure et ne9f sanctions j'ai
je pas je suis pas rentré dans le détail
pour voir queles étaient les les chaînes
concernées je pense que ce serait
intéressant pour les les les 15
renouvellements de voir un peu ce qu'il
y a dans la besace si vous me permettez
l'expression la question que que
j'ai c'est et est-ce que vous
considérez que notamment les sanctions
pécunières et les règles de sanctions
pécunière 3 4 5 % enfin je me rappelle
plus exactement 5 % en cas de
réitération 3 ou 4 % la première fois
est-ce que vous considérez qu'elles ont
un effet dissuasif au regard notamment
bah de la réitération pour certaines
chaînes de ces sanctions pécunières et
est-ce que vous appelez de vos
vœ que le législateur s'empare
éventuellement de la question un
durcissement de de ces sanctions
pécunières et la deuxième question sur
un autre sujet que je voudrais aborder
vous avez indiqué
que dans les critères que vous prenez en
en en compte il y a la question de la
diversité et notamment on a parlé du
pluralisme politique mais le CSA est
aussi chargé de veiller à la diversité
il publie d'ailleurs transmet chaque
année au Parlement un baromètre de la
représentation de la de la diversité euh
dont même s'il y a des progrès timorés
il y a quand même une récurrence sur les
sur les points de difficulté pour
reprendre les termes que vous utiliser
la faiblesse des personnes perçues comme
nom blanch dans les les programmes et
leur par contre leur surreprésentation
dans des euh des rôles à connotation
négatives euh leur faiblesse notamment
sur les chaînes d'information continue
la part des femmes qui restent à 39 % 40
% donc qui du mal à progresser le
handicap même chose les personnes âgées
alors c'est un sujet qui me tient à cœur
où là là il y a une chronicité d'un
décalage très fort 6 % de représentation
quand c'est 20 % de la population
française bref tout tous ces ces
élémentsl donnent lieu à des invitations
à faire est-ce que c'est un critère que
vous objectiverez pour constater sur
certaines des chaînes dans quelle mesure
là il y a des gaps très problématiques
et d'ailleurs est-ce que vous êtes
capable de regard des donn doné global
que vous publiez de de distinguer non
pas les bons ou les mauvais élèves mais
les résultats sur certains de ces sujets
sur chacune des chaînes et dans quelle
mesure vous en tiendrez compte si vous
estimez que là il y a des écarts à la
moyenne trop importants et qui atteste
non pas d'une insuffisance de prise en
compte mais peut-être d'une non volonté
délibéré de prise en compte de certaines
de ces
problématiques merci beaucoup monsieur
le député g de vos de vos questions donc
il va sen dire monsieur le Président
Monsieur le Rapporteur que l'arcom d'AB
sera naturellement à votre disposition
pour vous fournir tous les éléments qui
seront utiles à la conduite de vos de
vos de vos travaux euh et bien
évidemment on dressera le bilan que vous
avez souhaité de de toutes les sanctions
mis en demeure qui ont pu être prononcé
sur les 15 chaînes qui
arrivent en fin d'autorisation sur la
durée de sur la durée de leur de leur
convention
euh les sanctions 4 % du chiffre
d'affaires
c'est qui peut monter jusqu'à 5 % dans
le
cadre dans le cadre du de la récidive
pardon c'est c'est c'est pas mal je
rappelle que dans le règlement européen
sur les services numériques qui vient
d'être adopté là le fameux le fameux DSA
l'Union européenne a retenu le taux de 6
% pourit s'aligner dessus et monter un
petit peu une chaîne de la
TNT qui si je prends celle pour laquelle
on a prononcé cette année une amende 3
million et demi d'euros qui se cumule
avec d'autres amendes précédentes
puisque la même chaîne sur sur cette
année a cumulé plusieurs plusieurs
sanctions c'est une chaîne qui à ce jour
est déficitaire et donc ces sanctions
n'ont pas amélioré sa situation sa
situation économique faut-il les
monter jeis jerais quand même dire ici
parce que je l'ai pas évoqué on a quand
même dans notre paysage
audiovisuel des des opérateurs
audiovisuel qui sont des grandes
entreprises pour beaucoup d'entre elles
euh avec des dirigeants qui sont des
dirigeants responsables euh qui
connaissent les obligations qui sont les
leurs et et le fait qu'en définitive le
régulateur ne sanctionne pas tant que ça
c'est quand même aussi le fait qu'on est
dans un paysage qui est maintenant
régulé depuis 40 ans où chacun connaît
la règle du jeu quand on prononce une
sanction elle est sur un éditeur mais
tous les autr auditeurs comprennent ce
que ça veut dire ça veut dire que dans
un même cas de figure le régulateur
procédera de de la de la même façon donc
voilà le fait d'avoir une politique
d'intervention qui se fait d'abord
chaque fois que c'est justifié
juridiquement de de façon pro
proportionné en fonction de la nature du
manquement trois dans un nombre qui est
pas qui est loin d'être ridicule mais
qui est pas non plus considérable c'est
quand même l'illustration d'un paysage
audiovisuel qui est régulé je je dis ça
parce que à contrario sur la sphère
numérique c'est le far wouest
aujourd'hui monsieur le
député sur le conflit du Proche Orient
que vous suivez de près comme nous bien
sûr qu'on a eu des dérapages sur les
médias audiovisuels traditionnels on a
été amené Inter venir sur certains
d'entre eux il y a des procédures qui
sont en cours sur d'autres mais le motif
de préoccupation majeur c'est sur les
plateformes numériques aujourd'hui et la
Commission européenne avec le
commissaire breton au titre du DSA a
engagé des procédures à l'égard de
plusieurs de ces opérateurs notamment x
auquel nous apportons notre concours d'
d'ors et déjà donc voilà il faut il faut
bien cerner aussi les enjeux on a un
enjeu majeur devant nous aujourd'hui qui
sont les acteurs du numérique ça veut
pas dire que les acteur audiovisuel
traditionnels sont dédouanés mais voilà
le fait qu'au bout de 40 ans nos
interventions soi dans des proportion de
chiffres raisonnbles c'est quand même
aussi le fruit d'une régulation qui
bonormalant porte porte ses fruits sur
la diversité on a un véritable
sujet effectivement on publie un
baromètre chaque année puisque la loi
impose aux médias audiovisuels de donner
une juste représentation de la diversité
de la société française on le fait par
des outils de nature incitative
aujourd'hui donc à la fois ce baromètre
qui est un rendez-vous annuel
public devant devant les
médias qui permet de nommer les choses
de dire les choses ça fait 10 ans que ce
baromètre existe donc permet de prendre
en compte les les tendances il y a des
domaines sur lesquels on
progresse madame calvz l'évoquera
peut-être sur la place des femmes dans
les médias tout n'est pas gagné mais on
avance euh on n'est pas complètement à
la parité mais on s'en rapproche il y a
des domaines où il faut encore
progresser la politique le
sport on voit bien qu'il y a encore des
efforts à gagner mais mais mais on
avance il y a d'autres domaines sur
lesquels on est effectivement très en
retard dans les médias la représentation
des personnes en situation de
handicap les personnes âgées que vous
avez évoqué certains territoires qu'on
voit peu dans les médias euh et et et
c'est vrai des médias qui ne ressemblent
pas au français ce sont des médias dont
on se détourne la faible confiance qu'on
accorde aux médias qui est mesuré chaque
année dans le baromètre quantard et dans
dans dans des enquêtes diverses qui sont
faites sur sur le sujet c'est c'est
aussi lié au fait qu'on ne se retrouve
pas dans dans dans des médias comme
comment croire un média dans lequel on
ne se voit jamais donc là il y a
incontestablement
une appréciation
et les engagements que les candidats
peuvent prendre sur ce terrain-là dans
leur candidature sera un critère
d'appréciation bien évidemment de la
part du du régulateur et deuxièmement je
je le dis de je le dis je l'ai dit tout
à l'heure je le répète puisque vous me
posez la question l'un des critères
d'appréciation c'est le respect par
l'éditeur des engagement qu'il a pris
devant le régulateur et notamment bien
évidemment les manquements qu'il a
commis sont un élément d'appréciation de
la part du du régulateur ce n'est pas le
seul puisque la loi nous fixe une série
de critères prioritaires mais ces
élémentsl sont des éléments que le
régulateur prendra en compte merci
Madame
Calvez merci monsieur le Président
Monsieur le Rapporteur monsieur le
Président de l'arcom merci d'inaugurer
ces auditions de la commission d'enquête
à ce stade j'aurais deux points
d'interrogation le premier vous venez de
l'évoquer l'évoquer c'est l'autorité de
régulation de la communication
audiovisuelle et numérique l'arcom qui a
pour mission de favoriser la juste
représentation des femmes et des hommes
sur les antennes et de contribuer à la
lutte contre les discriminations en
raison du sexe une action de contrôle
une action d'incitation sur l'action de
contrôle de cette juste représentation
comment avez-vous renforcé vos moyens de
contrôle notamment par les apports de la
technologie pour monitorer plus plus
souvent et mieux dans quelle mesure en
respectant le maintien des cahiers des
charges qu'on comprend bien pouvez-vous
renforcer votre moyen de ô en période de
crise comment s'en inspirer pour
améliorer le contrôle de la juste
représentation de la diversité de la
société deuxème point d'explication ce
sera
sur un point qui me paraît important
c'est de relever que les canaux TNT sont
un bien commun précieux leur attribution
c'est la mise à disposition du domaine
public qui entraîne les obligations que
vous contrôler je voudrais vous inviter
à répondre à deux réflexions d'une part
vous avez évoqué la l'importance du
caractère fédérateur de la TNT rappelez
que pour 20 % de nos concitoyens c'est
le moyen unique d'accès au service de
télévision pour autant devant
l'évolution des autres moyens de
diffusion devant des conventions ou qu'
des charges qui obligent ne
craignez-vous pas une désaffection de la
TNT et de constater un manque de
candidat au moment des attributions que
se passe-t-il concrètement s'il n'y a
aucun
candidat pour éviter cette hypothèse
comment la qualification de service
d'intérêt général les siges à ces
chaînes pourrai contribuer à rendre plus
attractifs ces canaux TNT d'autre part
et vous avez parlé des états généraux de
l'information et de l'importance du
droit à l'information pourriez-vous nous
rappeler la place que l'information sur
ces chaînes TNT représente vous nous
avez souligné qu'une des spécificités
françaises c'était d'avoir quatre
chaînes d'infoue mais comment
globalement la TNT se consacre à
l'information combien d'heures par
exemple et d'après vous dans quelle
mesure elle a évolué et pourrait avoir
peut-être davantage de place pour
favoriser notre droit à l'information
puisque ces canaux sont des biens
publics pourquoi ne pas favoriser
davantage la place d'un bien commun
celui du droit à l'information
indépendante et pluraliste je vous
remercie merci beaucoup madame la la
députée sur sur votre première question
l'appel aux
technologies
pour monitorer contrôler oui c'est tout
à fait une piste que nous sommes en
train de
d'examiner de voir comment des outils
d'intelligence artificielle pourrai nous
aider dans un certain nombre de
processus que nous sommes amenés à à
gérer au titre de la de la régulation
puisqu'on a un certain nombre de de
nature de contrôle qui nous amène à
brasser des données et on voit bien les
progrès que ce type d'outil pourrait
nous apporter sur un domaine que vous
connaissez parfaitement celui de la
place des femmes dans les médias vous
connaissez le partenariat que nous avons
avec l'Institut national de
l'audiovisuel qui nous permet de de
mesurer les temps d'expression la
présence et le temps d'expression des
femmes dans dans les médias et vous
connaissez tout l'intérêt de cet outil
qui n qui nous a permis de voir que même
si quantitativement les femmes sont plus
présentes dans les médias néanmoins
elles s'expriment moins qu'elles ne sont
vu si jeose dire parce que leur parole
est plus rare ou qu'elles sont plus
interrompues par par les hommes donc
donc c'est tout à fait une une piste que
nous avons en tête deux et ça rejoint la
question du député Edge tout à l'heure
je je le dis ici dans les critères
d'appréciation des candidatures tous ces
critères qui sont évoqués notamment
l'article 31 de la loi de 86 qui touche
aux thématiques que vous avez évoqué
ceux de la diversité au sens large et
ceux de de de la place des femmes c'est
un critère d'appréciation dans la
densification des conventions que nous
avons conclu récemment avec des
opérateurs dont nous avons renouvelé
l'autorisation TF1 M6 c'est des points
justement euh tout ce volet des des
obligations sociétales sur lequel on a
mis davantage
l'accent c'est des circonstances et
renégociations de convention où on
essaie de planter le drapeau plus loin
si je peux dire pour avancer sur ces sur
ces thématique et et et donc de de
densifier de densifier les obligations
des opérateurs en la matière
conformément à l'objectif du du
législateur qui sera candidat et est-ce
qu'on aura euh
beaucoup de
candidats vous vous verrez dans la
synthèse de la consultation publique
qu'on va publier dans dans très peu de
jours ce que ce que je retiens
c'est l'intérêt et la pétence pour pour
la
TNT au moins de la part des opérateurs
en place est-ce qu'il y aura des
outsiders c'est bien évidemment la
grande inconnue de l'audiovisuel et du
monde des affaires donc je peux pas je
peux pas préjuger de de ce qui se
produira comme vous le savez sur le
dernière le dernier appel qu'on a lancé
sur les fréquences rendu disponibles par
TF1 et M6 on avait trois candidats pour
pour deux fréquences est-ce est-ce que
ça se reproduira euh je ne sais pas euh
on verra
euh il est possible s'il y a pas d'abord
d'abord il est possible qu'on ne
retienne pas des candidatures je le
redis ici au regarde des critères posés
par la loi et de l'appréciation que le
régulateur pour appter sur les dossiers
de candidature s'il y a pas de candidat
sur une fréquence bien il faudra
relancer une procédure une fois après
bien évidemment onattribuera pas dans le
vide une fréquence sur laquelle il y a
pas de il y a pas de de
candidat sur l'information l'information
elle tient une place prépondérante sur
ces chaînes
elle est l'ordre de grandeur en tout cas
c'est plus de 20 % de leurs programmes
sont consacrés à l'information alors
notamment parce que dans les chaînes
quiar à échéance il y a bien sûr les
chaînes d'information mais globalement
sur la TNT la première nature de
programme en pourcentage c'est la
télévision c'est c'est l'information
pardon donc c'est un peu plus de un peu
plus de 20 % en avance sur la en avance
sur la les aspects de création et les
services d'intérêts généraux c'est un
dossier sur lequel on staturera dans les
très vite
maintenant je je le dis aux membres de
la commission c'est une disposition
d'une directive européenne qui est
transposée dans notre droit qui permet
d'imposer aux interfaces qui permettent
d'accéder au contenu audiovisuel
notamment constructeur de de chaînes de
télévision une bonne exposition de nos
acteurs nationaux donc le service public
qui est fléché directement par la loi
mais aussi les les acteurs privés et le
régulateur sera très attentif à faire en
sorte que nos opérateurs nationaux
au titre de cette procédure des services
d'intérêts généraux soit exposés aussi
avantageusement que des acteurs privés
payant plateforme de streaming ou autres
pour qu'on ait pas là aussi une
asymétrie de d'accès sur nos écrans avec
des acteurs très puissants notamment
nord-américains par rapport à nos à nos
acteurs nationaux donc c'est oui un
paramètre de valorisation de la TNT
auquel on sera très très attentif au
même titre que l'ultra haute définition
pour offrir aux
téléspectateurs une qualité de programme
en TNT euh voilà haute
gamme merci monsieur le Président je
donne la parole à Monsieur deini que je
remercie pour sa patience et chers
collègues je vaisai sur les prochaines
table rondes et auditions alterné de
manière à ce que puissiez être largement
remonté la prochaine
fois merci monsieur le Président
Monsieur le Président chers collègues je
hier vous avez euh été effectivement en
commission culture au Sénat vous avez
évoqué les sujets qui font l'objet d'un
réflexion approfondie pour préparer
l'avenir du secteur et notamment moi je
souhaiterais vous interroger sur les
deux critères que vous avez sur les deux
derniers critères que vous avez évoqué
donc la lutte contre la désinformation
et les ingérences étrangères à quel
moyen pensez-vous pour mettre en place
une action pour lutter contre contre ces
deux phénomènes euh également dans le
cadre de la protection de la liberté
d'expression et du pluralisme des
médias quel nouveau moyens pensez-vous
pour assurer la protection on l'a vu
dans
l'affaire de Madame la Ministre Rima
abdoumak contre ces news qui est allé
jusqu'à poser la question du retrait de
la fréquence de la chaîne alors je
savais pas aujourd'hui qu'on était là
pour assister un procès de ces news pu
même peut-être d'un d'un procès en
prudomme de cette chaîne
mais en l'occurrence voilà c'est une
une une information enfin une un propos
de la ministre qui a eu un peu choquant
dans le cadre de la séparation et de
l'indépendance de votre organisme donc
si vous pouvz nous donner des éléments
je vous
remercie merci monsieur le député alors
le premier sujet est bienement essentiel
il va être très important dans la
perspective du du scrutin européen de
juin
2024 il nous il nous mobilise d'ors et
déjà vous savez que le
l'arcom pour chaque scrutin doit prendre
une délibération qui fixe le cadre du
contrôle du pluralisme qui sera
déployé dans le cadre de ce scrutin donc
on on prendra ces
délibération au début de l'année
prochaine donc pour encadrer la la
campagne des élections des élections
européennes et puis on participera bien
évidemment à la à l'organisation de la
campagne officielle euh qui est prévu
sur les médias de service public en
particulier euh deuxièmement on a une
compétence qui vient de la
loi relative à la lutte contre la
manipulation de l'information de
décembre 2018 qui nous amène dans ces
périodes électorales à dialoguer de
façon plus étroite avec les plateforme
numérique c'est ce que nous avons fait
pour le scrutin présidentiel et
législatif de l'année dernière on avait
réuni toutes les plateformes dès le mois
de janvier on les avait réunis tous les
15 jours pour avoir un un dispositif de
dialogue et et et de signalement de tout
ce qui pouvait relever de la
manipulation de l'information bien
évidemment pas pas de ce qui relève du
débat politique du combat politique
j'allais dire bon chacun a le droit
d'échanger ses arguments mais ce qui
relève potentiellement de la
manipulation de l'information et puis on
a et et on voit bien cont tenu des
mouvements géopolitiques sur le
continent européen un un gros
risque certainement d'intrusion dans le
cadre de ces processus électoraux c'est
des choses qu'on a déjà connu par le
passé peu en
2022 mais l'élection au Parlement
européens va revêtir chacun en la
conscience cont tenu des des mouvements
électoraux déjà opérés dans un certain
nombre de pays de de l'Union comp tenu
des mouvements géopolitiques auxquels je
viens faire allusion et notamment des
des conflits qui sont
aux frontières de de l'Union peut
exposer ce scrutin à des risques
d'ingérance importants donc vous savez
que la France s doté d'un d'un service à
compéten nationale qui est placé auprès
du secrétaire général de la défense et
de la sécurité nationale qui s'appelle
viginum l'arcom est associé à la
gouvernance de de viginum donc nous
avons un dialogue étroit et régulier
avec ce ce service du fait de notre
proximité maintenant avec les les grands
acteurs du du numérique j'ai j'ai
moi-même rencontré il y a il y a peu de
temps le secrétaire général de de la
défense et de la sécurité nationale pour
échanger avec lui là-dessus et et voir
comment on s'organisait pour le le
scrutin à venir donc c'est des
préoccupation que nous aurons tout à
fait en tête et on on réunira en amont
nous-même les grandes les grandes
plateformes dans la perspective de ce
scrutin
euh s'agissant du pluralisme bon je
crois avoir largement répondu à la
question parmi nos critères
d'appréciation des des candidatures je
je l'ai dit il y a un critère central
qui est le pluralisme pluralisme des
acteurs pluralisme et diversité de de
l'offre intérêt du intérêt du
téléspectateur vous avez utilisé le mot
procès je crois que je me suis tenu à
distance de tout commentaire à l'égard
de toute chaînes de télévision et
notamment de celles qui sont
susceptibles d'ê être candidate au
processus donc vous n'entendrez pas ce
mot dans dans ma bouche
euh on appréciera les candidatures pour
ce qu'elles valent au regard des
critères qui sont posés par la loi et on
le fera en toute indépendance en toute
impartialité et de manière collégiale je
je n'ai pas assez insisté ce matin sur
le fait que rien de ce qui sort de cette
autorité n'est délibéré n'est pas
délibéré par le le collège toutes ces
décisions sont prises par neuf membres
les membres du collège c'est pas moi qui
les ai choisis le collège que je préside
aujourd'hui n'a rien à voir avec celui
que j'ai présidé le jour où j'ai pris
mes fonctions il s'est renouvelé puisque
se renouvelle partière tous les 2 ans
c'est pas moi qui choisit ses membres
c'est pas moi qui les nomme il y a
toutes les sensibilités c'est un collège
paritaire il y a des juristes très
chevronnés dans ce collège un membre du
Conseil d'État une magistrate à la Cour
de cassation une ancienne directrice
juridique de l'Autorité de la
concurrence l'impartialité et la
collégialité sont pour nous deux
éléments structurants de notre vie
quotidienne merci monsieur le Président
si vous me permettez peut-être très
rapidement juste une une petite question
pour terminer quel est votre champ
d'action sur les chaînes hors TNT euh et
je pense également à l'incident enfin en
tout cas au programme pour lequel vous
avveait déjà répondu hein de de
Paramount plus et de MTV France euh
c'està dire quel nation et qu'elle
travaille avec les autres régulateurs
européens justement aussi pour répondre
lorsque les les diffuseurs ne sont pas
sur le sol
national alors l'espace européen
l'espace médiatique européen est un
espace qui est qui est protégé bien
évidemment donc nous nous régulons comme
chacun de nos homologues européens les
les acteurs qui sont présents sur notre
territoire mais nous sommes amenés à à
réguler soit nous-mêm soit soit nos
homologues des
acteurs qui qui ne sont pas situés sur
notre territoire mais qui nous ciblent
donc il il y a plusieurs cas de figure
et je pense c'est intéressant de de
l'évoquer y compris par rapport à ce
qu'on a pu vivre avec le
conflit entre le la Fédération de Russie
et l'Ukraine où ce qu'on vit en ce
moment au titre du conflit entre Israël
et le et le Hamas euh on a des chaînes
qui sont
extraeuropéennes qui peuvent diffuser
par voix satellitaire et toucher notre
territoire ces chaînes n'échappent pas à
la protection de l'espace européen tel
qu'il est défini dans la directive
service médias audiovisuel tel qu'il est
défini par la loi de 86 donc il nous est
arrivé lors de la la
séquence du conflit entre la Fédération
de Russie et l'Ukraine de demander à
Helsa de mettre en demeure Helsa de
bloquer la diffusion de chaînne euh qui
diffusaiit des contenus qui n'étaient
pas conformes avec avec la
réglementation euh la la question s'est
posée également dans le cadre du du
conflit du conflit au proche- Orient sur
le cas de médias comme celui que vous
auquel vous avez fait allusion donc ce
programme French Shore qui est diffusé
par paramon plus d'une part et par MTV
d'autre part qui sont des des programmes
payants c'est des Programm qui ne
partent pas de de la France donc qui
relève de la responsabilité du
régulateur chèque pour l'un berlinois
pour pour l'autre donc nous avons saisi
nos deux nos deux collègues de ces deux
pays pour qu'il s'assure que ces
programmes une fois encore c'est des
programmes payantsin sont pas en accès
libre sont sont bien conformes à la
réglementation notamment en terme de de
protection des de protection des mineurs
donc c'est une enquête qui est en cours
de de leur part donc on on verra ce
qu'il en est on est bien évidemment
intervenu également auprès de ma de
TikTok de X parce que l'une des
difficultés principales ça a été le fait
que ces contenus ont été viralisés sur
les réseaux sociaux et donc c ces
plateformes à notre demande ont accéléré
les les modérations par intelligence
artificielle sur sur ces sur ces
contenus donc c'est c'est tout l'intérêt
de de c'était pour moi l'une des
priorités de mon mandat c'est de faire
rentrer cette régulation dans le monde
qui est le notre monde d'aujourd'hui et
voilà c'est tout l'enjeu de la
régulation des années qui viennent nos
médias audiovisuels on en a parlé ce
matin on peut trouver que on peut faire
plus ceci plus cela mais ils sont
globalement régulés et globalement bien
régulés je crois la sphère numérique on
est au début de l'histoire et ce
règlement européen sur les services
numériques c'est ça va être une priorité
l'arcom comme vous savez au titre du du
projet de loi sren qui viendra en
commission mix paritaire lui aussi euh
au début de l'année prochaine devrait
être désigné comme autorité nationale
pour pour la mise en œuvre de ce
règlement et c'est un un des gros
chantiers sur lequel on est très
mobilisé sur lequel l'organisation de la
maison c'est c'est beaucoup adapté
depuis 2
ans c'est bon pouros monsieur le
rapporteur monsieur le Président Madame
la Directrice Monsieur le Directeur
Général merci beaucoup pour votre
participation et l'ensemble des réponses
effectivement je pense qu'on restera on
va dire à flu tendu avec l'instance que
vous représentez tout au long de la
mission on aura beaucoup de de choses à
vous demander je vous propose bien sûr
de compléter nos échanges en envoyant
secrétariia les documents que vous jugez
utile à la commission d'enquête on a
déjà cité l'organigramme on a également
cité le le bilan des sanctions
prononcées c'était d'ailleurs la
question 4.4 du du questionnaire qui
vous avait été préalablement envoyé vous
pouvez effectivement faire part aussi de
réponse écrite aux 10 questionnaires
chers collègues nous avons passé presque
2h30 d'audition mais c'était
effectivement important et structurant
de d'avoir un temps long avec l'arcom et
et son président nos auditions
reprendront donc à 14h nous aurons deux
tables rondes avec des des
universitaires chercheurs sur ces sujets
la séance est levée je vous
remerci